anthony mativier is a memory expert
who's had a troubled life
and through the odds managed to change
his blighted scenario into a salubrious
philosophical framework regarding
consciousness
meditation and memory based on what he
calls oneness
what separates anthony from other memory
trainers is that he doesn't focus on
long strings of digits for memorization
or training for championships
but instead for memorizing information
that actually improves your daily life
anthony responds to emails fairly
quickly and with length
you can find out more about them at
magneticmemorymethod.com
links to all that's referenced in the
podcast is in the description
if you'd like to hear more conversations
like this then please consider
supporting
at patreon.com slash kirchheim uncle
i've also recently opened up
a crypto address which means if you'd
like to facilitate my foray into crypto
and donate any amount whatsoever then
please do so
it seems like the value of most of these
currencies tend to be on the increase
and i'm willing to hold on to whatever's
given in order to find out how far that
trend
will go paypal is also an option and is
linked below as well
thank you so much and enjoy
if you see me look off to the side
anthony it's because
i'm listening to you but i also need to
pay attention to
any questions that people have when it's
live but as much as i can i'm going to
try and just focus exclusively on you
so the people who are watching who are
listening who want to chat if i'm not
responding to you that's a good sign
because it means that i'm here in the
moment
in the podcast and that's probably a
better viewing experience
the negative is that i don't get to your
question in real time
well that's the question though is
anything off to the side not in the
moment
i had a professor actually who said that
the the center is always the margin
and the margin is always the center so
he was referring to like pop culture
with madonna
and all this sort of stuff like anything
that
madonna is popularizing is always coming
from the margin
that somehow then seems to be in the
center um
and then as soon as it gets too popular
then people want to push it back to the
margin and somehow call it fringe
but in any case it's all in
consciousness
i would say not a memory champion though
i only ever
had one competition and
in that competition i came second so
but nonetheless
although you know i did get what is
called the warrior of the mind emblem
for outstanding contributions to
global mental literacy from tony buzan
who created
the world memory championships so
that is its own triumph so to speak
great great great great if you see me
frantic
anthony or anyone who's watching it's
because i just came from
this is my fourth podcast for the day my
last one so don't worry i'm here with
you for as long as you're
willing to spend some time with me and i
also
don't have the question see most of the
time what i do is a prodigious amount of
research
and it's as if i'm on a boat and i'm
heavily steering it
for this one
i have notes not printed in front of me
like usual
which means i'll have to press alt tab
and check my notes occasionally
but i thought that in the spirit of this
in the spirit of what you're about which
is how about we
float freely in the waters let the
universe take us where it may
i thought how about let this
conversation take us or it may
please do or please allow it anthony why
don't you tell the audience a little bit
about
where you started from in your
intellectual journey so that's maybe
you're around teenager late teens or so
what your ideological i don't like to
use that word ideology but
for the sake of using a word that people
believe they understand
your ideological disposition at the time
and then how it changed and where you
are now
okay well i don't normally talk about
the teenage years but
i was pretty much a depressed
kind of musician kid who skipped school
as much as possible
to smoke weed and drink beer and play
with my band and
write angry lyrics for the singer to
sing
and my earliest experiences really
were of being a just dropping out of
high school and reading the encyclopedia
i didn't read it page for page but we
had this old colliers
encyclopedia encyclopedia yeah yeah and
i just went through that
from beginning to end you know again not
every single page but
it was just the most amazing experience
and i used to walk
uh to pretend that i was going to school
and listen to cbc radio
uh peter zoski was alive at the time i
think it was morningside it was called
and you were in toronto or you were
where this is in british columbia
oh so i was in salmon arm which is
some nowhere place yeah if you see me go
like this
that's because for the people listening
or watching this there's a bit of a
delay
because anthony's in australia if i'm
correct yes
right and i'm in toronto and so if i
need to get a
all of this gets edited out eventually
when i
put up the pristine version of this
podcast but for now it's going to be
messy
and i forgot to ask you to record your
audio if you don't mind doing so
it's recording okay great great just
your own audio your instructions
yes yeah thank you man thank you and i'm
sorry to rudely interrupt if you don't
mind continuing
no not at all yeah so i wasn't in
toronto yet but i was in
salmon arm even silver creek which is
outside of salmon arm this very nowhere
place
and uh listening to peter zoski and he
would bring in the most amazing guests
uh that gave me far more of an education
than high school ever did
and what ended up happening is i went to
graduate with my friends
even though i wasn't graduating and one
of my friends mothers who
had inspired me so much when i was a
teenager going to her house and seeing
all the books
that she had she was a professor at york
actually
she said what the hell you're not
graduating
you should be a professor when you grow
up and somehow that uh got in my head
this image of being the professor
and you know it's kind of sucked
not going to school and knowing that i
was going gonna have a life of
no education because at that time i
think it was true that if you didn't
have your
high school degree you know it would be
very difficult to get a job
and so um i took i i took the
embarrassing
step of going back to high school and
then i got myself into university and i
mean it's a long story the university
but
in terms of ideology i don't know that i
distinctly remember what it was but i
started
university in political science that was
going to be my uh focus
and i was working for the the school
newspaper
editing writing stories and so forth and
i met i think his name was glenn kemp
not glenn campbell that doesn't sound
right glenn clark maybe
and he had been the premier of bc at the
time and um
i interviewed him and i thought within
three minutes
i never want anything to do with
political science again or politicians
and so i went and changed my degree to
english literature and um
yeah but why what was it about what was
it about politics
uh i just could tell he was lying to me
and
you know i i i don't know where i get
that but i just don't like
this kind of dual track modulating
of what's going on and yeah it just felt
so false to me
and i thought this guy's a tyrant and if
i remember that word coming up to
and i'd been reading you know plato's
republic and all this sort of stuff at
that time it was just the first time
encountering all those ideas
um and i just thought if i go that route
i'll be like this guy
and so i wanted to get as far away from
that as possible
uh so that was
where that puts me ideologically i don't
know but i had been reading lots of
you know existentialist literature and
philosophy and
was really into people like don delillo
in literature whatever that means uh in
terms of
of a an ideology but it seems
quite uh of a lot of different
chaotic elements going on in the world
and not getting too involved
in any of them so you can have the
widest possible perspective
and make decisions based on some sort of
rational basis wherever possible
were you a quick reader always i'd say
i'd say i'm relatively quick but
slow enough to pay attention
so then what happened so you're in your
university years early i know that it
took you
quite some time to getting your phd and
that was because of quite a bit of
itinerancy and your
choices to what you precisely want but
why don't you continue through that rob
yeah well i had started university in
british columbia at a small college
in uh salmon arm which is okanagan
university college which i think now is
subsumed by ubc
um and then i was in university of
northern british columbia which is way
up in prince george
somehow an uncle of mine had said why
don't you come work the summer
at para paints which is in brampton in
toronto
and i did that and i kind of liked it
there and i wound up
applying to university of toronto
university of toronto wanted
accepted me but only on a part-time
basis and i didn't want to go to
university part-time i don't know why
it had something to do with like i had
really bad high school
grades because that's interesting yeah i
dropped out and
i mean i i never cared about high school
at all i remember
one time i had an a on my report card
and i tore it up
i was embarrassed that i had a good
grade uh
which was in literature of course why
i think it was probably dramatic showing
off at the time i was
in front of my friends in the band and
we were sharing each other's report
cards and they all had bad grades and i
heard i had this a and they're like what
are you doing
or whatever but i i remember touring it
up as a sort of theatrical
thing to do so you have this
romanticization of what it means to be
this nihilist rock person
yeah i mean it it was 1993
well i graduated uh i was supposed to
graduate 95 so i graduated 96 but
somewhere in 93 94 this is when i got
this grade
it was like nine inch nails pretty hate
machine hate everybody hate yourself
hate success uh and all the bands i
followed if they weren't
bootstrapped fugazi kind of indie
do-it-yourself people
then they were somehow
anti-establishment or
at least they were preaching that you
know later you investigate this and
there's a lot more corporate interest in
it than you thought at the time but
um you know what i noticed about
you mentioned when you were interviewing
someone i forget the person's name glenn
maybe it was some
political science person and then you
realized they had this pretext or a
facade
and you didn't want anything to do with
that what i noticed
is there are these artists nowadays ever
since
kurt cobain but kurt cobain was genuine
if you watch kurt cobain
he's authentic in his distaste for
culture and his distaste for
values of a certain kind he was a
nihilist in some ways he was
there's this romanticization of
nihilists in
pop culture in popular music that has
grown ever since kurt cobain you've even
see it with artists nowadays with
i don't remember who but you just look
at the music videos and you see how
they're singing like
like like they're trying not to sing
like they're trying to
appear like they're not trying and i see
it as false nihilism i see it as a
facade
as well because they're admiring what
it's like to be a nihilist
or more particularly they admire what
being a nihilist a popular nihilist gets
you someone like
i don't know this person's name dua lipa
or lipa duo
people in the comments section can
correct me i'm not familiar with modern
music
but that's something i see it's not just
politicians that have this masquerading
it's
it's all of us it's me it's something i
was i saw in a
as i was watching an interview with
someone named chris williamson i'm
pretty sure some
he's a has a famous a fairly famous
podcast
he was interviewing someone who
i forget her name pamela or has two p's
whatever it doesn't matter she studies
high performers right when you watch her
speak
you get the sense that you're not
speaking to the person when i'm speaking
to you right now i get the sense that i
am speaking to you that you're being
genuine
you can tell because someone trips over
their words someone is
pausing as they think someone is like
yourself someone is
laughing at at different moments in
their own story
someone is hiding and recoiling from the
parts that they're embarrassed about
like
subconsciously rather than a
manufactured appearance and when i was
watching
chris interview her let me get her name
not to not to berate her but she has the
same quality even though she is
completely apolitical as far as i could
see she's the same quality of
politicians and i dislike that
yeah that's another reason why i'm
speaking to you completely off the cuff
sorry not completely off the cuff i do
have some notes but why i've made
one page of notes rather than 10 pages
compared to the usual guest
because i want it to freely float in
this stream of
uncertainty with you let me get that
person's life just
so i can move on yeah well i'll just say
that
that pretense is is deeply alarming
and i think it's deeply alarming to
culture as such even if people don't
realize it
uh you see it in you see it in our
productions
all the time but when you since you
mentioned cobain i mean
he gave one of the greatest gifts in one
of his
interviews where he was just being
himself and they're asking him what he
reads
and he said that he read patrick
suskin's
perfume which is a novel that's
very much about this you know this crazy
person who can't stand the stench of
things
and aha perfume right right right that's
interesting
which is a highly interesting novel to
read and it's a very good novel
and this is this is where i think the
question gets super interesting
because here's cobain who you know
where is he is he an ils is he pop
culture is he
anti-pop culture what is this sort of
thing and he's reading a
deeply cultured german
novel translated in english i would
assume but you know suskin
is not a lightweight or you know some
vagabond novelist right turns out he's
highly cherished and you know top
top-notch blue ribbon
in europe etc and you you can
really see the the collapse i think in a
lot of
this sort of pretense i'm not i don't
know exactly what i'm trying to get to
but one thing that comes to mind is when
i was a kid in kamloops british columbia
we were between seattle and calgary
basically
or vancouver and calgary but you know
the
a lot of bands came through and they
would stop and one of them was green day
and when we saw green day as kids this
was the most amazing thing
ever and we had no idea that one day
they were going to do this album
called dookie and become this
international
smash hit we had no idea it was just
some band called green day
a couple of the kids had the shirt we
all remembered because the drummer
had bounced his sticks off the floor tom
and
was doing all these stunts and it just
was the most memorable concert i think
they played with
roll cage which was a local band etc
years later
everybody's like oh they sold out but we
saw them when they were real
and all this sort of stuff and my
question at that time was
well and i'm you know what is real
you know we call this guy blue but it's
not really blue and i'm
already a philosophical sort of oriented
individual
and i it rubbed me the wrong way that
people would say
we saw these guys when they were real
but now that they have massive radio
play
and they're on you know the music video
all the time
now that's somehow not real and
later if i skip forward to university in
toronto i was
i loved the poetry scene there you know
screaming high park was the most amazing
thing to go to during those years and
seeing guys like steve mccaffrey and
christian book
doing poetry readings and whatnot in
toronto
there would you'd always hear these
people talking about
how that they were masters of the craft
and then they would
with their creative writing you know
salaries berate people like stephen king
as garbage
and uh because he was successful
yeah and i came up with this theory
called craft and it was spelled
c-r-a-p-h-t right and uh
it's like crap they're just calling all
of this
successful stuff crap because it
succeeds
and then you look at stephen king and he
has this amazing quote somewhere he's
like if you've ever sold a piece of
writing
and then taken that money and used it to
pay the electricity bill
then i call you talented and so there's
like this war
going on but you know who is it that's
that's doing the complaining in this war
and so forth and it's usually some sort
of
nietzschean slave morality where that
you know
this or that is less real or this or
that is less genuine or this
that is less authentic and when you
listen to the people who are making
these claims
i'm not saying that this is always the
case but it seems usually to be coming
from people
who have some sort of invested interest
in
creating a symbolic suffering right now
for these people
to vent their hatred or their anger or
their jealousy or their envy or whatever
it is
and that's like that's the deep sickness
here uh
that that i see in all these sorts of
issues because
if there's no free will and if life is
as chaotic as it appears to be
these people who become successful don't
have nearly as much choice in it
as it seems and it's it's not as if they
could have said i'm going to be
successful one day i'm going to sell out
that's my plan it just doesn't make any
sense
and our filters now somehow call it
garbage because it's successful
where does that filter come from what's
the survival mechanism here anyway
that's kind of just ripping on you
mentioning kurt cobain
but it's almost like a lot of these
people get into this
success and they they themselves hate it
you know because they didn't choose it
they didn't want it
and um that was certainly true of kurt
cobain
he couldn't bear his own success but
there are other people i think who
balance it quite healthy
with quite a bit of health you know they
managed to see the game for what it is
and they're like yeah you know inflation
is real
and i better make some investments and
you know build a boat around myself as
much as possible because the success
isn't going to last
but i like the comfort i have now and so
forth and you just see all kinds of
people playing all kinds of games
and some play it well some play it less
well some play it with
an artist ideology others play it with
some other thing
but they they gotta play you're forced
to play it and uh
i don't know it i've always found that
interesting anyway so pretense
i think that there's pretension in all
kinds of areas and it may have some
biological filter
it may have some nature nurture
complex going on but i don't think it's
as simple as
you know nihilism in kurt cobain's case
uh maybe but i i think it's i think that
the issues are pretty
pretty deep and and rich to sift and
sort and screen through
there's a certain kind of speech that
politicians definitely have
something that even though i'll get
excoriated for mentioning this something
that donald trump doesn't have
because donald trump speaks off the cuff
and you can tell as much as people
dislike him and as much as whatever he
says
can be abhorrent at least you get the
feeling that he's
you know i'll get crit critiqued for
this as well i wouldn't even say that
he's speaking from the heart because
there is
there's plenty of what he says that is
opportunistic
and and manipulative as well but there's
a different kind of speech that
trump has than someone like
kamala harris camilla harris now
i'm not getting political i don't care
about the politics right now i'm merely
i'm merely stating that the feeling that
you got from interviewing that
politician and then saying i don't want
to be like that
that isn't just in politicians now i
managed to get the lady's name
and i don't mean to put this lady on the
spot
but i also don't like when you know what
sometimes people have stories that are
like
they give a story about a person then
you're like i wish i knew who they were
talking about but they don't
well i'm gonna say who i'm talking about
there's this person named chris williams
williamson now i like him actually
personally he's a podcaster but he
interviewed someone named
paulina pompliano the reason i'm saying
this is i would like some
people who are watching this podcast to
watch his podcast with her
now i i see paulina pompliano
she's not speaking about anything
political as far as i can tell
but she still has that same distancing
feeling
from from her speech in the sense that
you don't
you don't feel like she speaks like that
when she's not on camera you don't feel
like you're getting to talk to her
you feel like she has her talking points
and you can see it in the way that
someone
speaks in the sense that
maybe because i've been doing podcasts
all day i was talking in my previous
podcast that
the reason why i pause so often and i
look down and i look up and i close my
eyes and it's because i'm
i'm i'm trying to think
i'm trying to think and whatever you say
often
thoughts occur to me but they're often
contradictory and so
when you ask me a question not that you
ask me a question right now but when you
do ask me a question or when i have
something to say i'm fighting with
myself to make sure that what i'm saying
is
genuine that i'm not that i'm not
putting on a
that i'm not manufacturing my speech in
order to give a certain appearance
and that it is what i mean that it is
what i think and that it's
i try his best to be as loving as i can
now that's like
who can do that man that's actually
extremely extremely difficult
to be loving it's talking to someone
they're like oh no loving is easy no
loving is hard
loving is extremely hard because to love
if you
truly loved you would be like jesus
you'd be like buddha
man so much of what we say comes from
self-hate and hatred of others i also
wonder how much of hatred of others is
is purely self-hate that's something
else i'm exploring we can explore that
you probably thought about that
quite a bit either way i'm mentioning
that person's name
paulina pompliano because i want people
i'm requesting some help for people to
look at chris williamson's interview
with her
and to help me articulate what is it
about the way that she
speaks that is inauthentic she could be
completely authentic i could be wrong
but i see the same
characteristic in her that i see in
politicians like pamela harris
and even joe biden and even for sure
hillary clinton and even
not obama obama was genuine at least i
think so
he had much more of a genuine character
whatever that's my little rant please
i'm requesting some help whenever you
get the chance people who are watching
look at that okay now that i'm done my
little spiel do you mind
continuing about yours uh trajectory i'm
interested
i'm interested in these things you're
saying i don't know the the reference
that you're making to this uh
interview but it is true that there's a
lot of performativity and trained
performance
and processing and percolating that goes
goes on in real time what interests me
though is how you bring
buddha and jesus into this and you know
how do we even know anything about these
people right we often refer to them
and somehow we know more about the
current political figures
than we do about those figures but we
feel as if we know the image of a jesus
or a buddha so well
um but i'm pretty sure that if we
saw those people assuming jesus in
particular even existed
they'd have just as many ticks and
people would
look at them and say oh that's
pretentious or that's rehearsed or
that's
whatever and maybe all the more so in
the case of the buddha because there'd
be
i would assume a lot of well also jesus
a lot of textual memorization
and recitation of what they're doing so
i mean that's just
an interesting thing that comes up to
clarify when i say jesus i actually mean
more about the
the archetypal gene jesus than the
historical jesus so that is to say the
perfect man
i'm calling the perfect man in the
christian sense jesus now whether or not
jesus was
the actual perfect man historically
literally if one wants to take that
route
that's another issue so that's what i
mean when i say jesus
okay so you then went to get your phd in
what subject
well humanities so
it was kind of a weird thing because the
humanities program didn't exist before
that i entered it and i was the first
cohort to go through it and
that was a very that was a big gamble i
guess to take a
phd in a topic that was that was brand
new
um but that's what i did and
i was able to focus on history of
religion history of
technology and science and do some
classics with
uh the classical world and languages and
whatnot
it's a great good breath it's a good mix
yeah yeah okay and then your work and
memory started
when and that led you to hear how
yeah it's a good question what i mean i
was very depressed
in university and here's like the big
sob story of the kid who
is struggling and blah blah blah but i
discovered memory
while i was near the end of my
uh coursework for the phd and starting
to prepare for the field exams
and think about what i was going to do
with my my dissertation
there's a long history of depression
going to
the hospital etc experimenting with
different
medications and so forth and uh camh
camh yeah that's the that's the hospital
in toronto for mental health
oh did they change the name of the clerk
because that's where i used to go
oh no i don't know about clark okay so
maybe it's used maybe it used to be
called that
yeah as in college in spadina yeah yeah
yeah yeah i used to call it the rook
because it kind of looks like a rook
piece in a chess a chess game
um but that's an interesting story in
and of itself because i
i knew about the clark because i had
read timothy findley's
head hunter and uh when i first wound up
there it was during my ba and i'd
written some crazy poem
and was pretty clearly in a manic
episode
and uh the ta of one of my courses said
he i'd come out of a lecture and i was
just crying from john keats it
touched me so deeply and
he'd read this poem that i'd written and
i was emailing to all my professors and
uh sort of a long story but he said you
know if you really
you what you're writing here is is good
but it's filled with all kinds of
strange
images and you know you're talking to us
you're trying to have this conversation
i had set up a poetry reading some
people were worried that i was going to
you know do
like a college shooting or something
like this because i was so focused on
this
poetry i really just wanted to read the
damn poem and then go to sleep
because i was tired i'd been up for
seven days writing this poem and the
the ta sent me to the clark anyway and i
knew exactly what it was because i'd
read timothy
uh finley's headhunter and uh
took me a while to get there but anyway
i didn't leave for three months after
that
after i showed up at the door at the
clark institute
so okay when you say you hadn't left for
three months do you mean to say that
they sequestered you they
put you in a room that you couldn't
escape from because they thought you
were a threat to yourself or someone
else
yeah worse than that i mean they i think
it was the fifth floor
and there's intensive care unit and so
it's almost like a prison
and so the floor is divided between sort
of general
open unit where there are rooms and
people can freely
move about and then the intensive care
which is sort of has these cells that
have
sliding doors and you're in there you're
locked into your own little room and
you come out into the day room only
certain during certain dirt
hours and the nursing station is behind
glass because there's people throwing
stuff at it etc
it was it was wild they gave you
medication or just talk therapy
well i didn't want medication i wasn't i
wasn't i wasn't yet convinced that i was
sick even though
i sort of knew that i had to go to the
hospital just because i wasn't sleeping
i don't know how long that i
waited before that i submitted to their
demands that i took take
the medication that they were suggesting
but
it was probably about three weeks or so
and
i remember having as long of
conversations as i possibly could have
with the doctors
and i would tell them you know what i
really need is
some sort of uh marxist
freudian psychoanalysis because it's
obvious
that you know the towers are beaming
capitalism into my head
and i was reading to lose so i was like
citing
capitalism and schizophrenia and all
this stuff
and i was convinced that the alphabet
was built from numbers and if you could
unwind the alphabet and see the
numerical structure of the universe
that you know whatever it was it was
pretty strange
stuff and i knew enough about psychology
i was
like i said maybe it's hebaphrenia and
all this
i don't even really know that i knew
what hepophrenia was but i was talk
i was telling them i was running the
show uh and
they were gonna let me burn out and
finally one day i guess something
convinced me to take lithium
and then i just you know was moved
eventually over to the
quote unquote general population then i
started to get
day passes and so forth and then
eventually i was released
how does lithium make you feel or how
did it
does it deaden your feelings yeah i
spent uh
maybe 10 years on lithium and
it is go like for me it was like going
into a no man's land
uh just very monotonous
i think i still am a bit of a monotonous
person now that i
do different practices to manage the
mental illness but
it's like having a bit of a mental
straight jacket on
and it also adds a layer of fat or it
added a layer of fat to me
and in toronto it was especially and new
york
both places i lived while i took lithium
it was quite dangerous in the summers
because during the humidity
you could get lithium toxic shock
or toxicity quite quite easily so you're
always playing this balancing game you
have to have the lithium levels just
right so that you're not
getting into trouble and you just feel
like you have to be babysat all the time
because you have to have the levels
checked you have to constantly get
new prescriptions and
it wasn't the solution but i didn't like
it
at all
for people listening or watching or
tuning in for the
for the right now for the first time and
not knowing who anthony is
anthony is a i wrongly called you a
memory champion but
you're somewhat of a memory expert you
certainly know the different techniques
and how to
quickly memorize virtually any piece of
of information that a regular memory
champion would
do as a almost parlor trick and you have
a tedx talk
now this one's interesting i watched it
it was about how to silence your
inner voice or inner critic or whatever
thoughts trouble you with
two questions and that one is a tedx
talk first of all that has a million
views
now tedx talks generally generally have
a few thousand to ten thousands
of views yours has a million and it was
released just last year which means it
doesn't even have
the advantage of being
on youtube for quite some time in order
to amass such
an amount of hits which means that the
quality is likely very
high so firstly congratulations on
getting
a million hits on tedx second people who
are
watching for the first time you can view
that talk it'll be in the description
okay anthony
why did you first reach out to me i
remember that we had some email
exchanges
why don't you tell me what precipitated
that
well first of all you have a great
channel
so that was one reason um
and i also had
i have a a project that i work on which
has to do with promoting memory training
so
i do know a lot about memory techniques
and
the competition history that i have is
very
sparse but i did compete for charity one
time and i actually did quite good
so it was it was a lot of fun i didn't i
didn't win for my charity
but i came in second so that that was
that was nice and i tell that story in
the uh
in the tedx how that all came to be in
very brief
strokes but anyway the techniques are
often used for
the outcome of winning competitions and
i find that
speaking of our earlier themes of
pretense i find that that
is not pretentious but it has this kind
of
turning of of a great tradition into
weightlifting essentially weightlifting
for the mind and so there's a lot of
people who are just there to show off
and they're not
really embracing the glory of memory
techniques
so what it what that glory is we can get
into but it has to do with learning
basically
and for the long term rather than
memorizing a bunch of stuff you're going
to forget after you get your middle
now in terms of reaching out to you you
had uh his name is richard heyer is it
um you had interviewed him and i was
i've been thinking about iq for a long
time and intelligence and so forth
and i thought if there's a way that
people can
before i saw your interview if there's a
way to
improve intelligence let's say
then what is the most likely way to do
it and it would be
to improve where intelligence sits
what is it that intelligence sits in and
so
that would be memory and so i just
basically reached out to you to let you
know that i'd linked to your interview
with him
and i thought that was an interesting
and compelling
discussion because he was talking about
potential drugs that might come in in
the future
and that makes sense to me and it seems
to go with my thesis which is
if you're going to improve memory you've
got to imp or improve intelligence
you've got to improve what
intelligence sits in and so if it's
going to be drugs what are those drugs
improving well they're going to improve
the brain
and brain is where memory sits and then
intelligence
i'm assuming sits or at least is somehow
in relationship with
memory as such but also very specific
levels of memory
so i just let you know that i was
linking to that
and also as a youtuber i'm always
fascinated with what other youtubers are
thinking and
suggested you know jamming on the topic
of youtube itself as a
as an initiative did you find any
methods to increase one's iq
i read your article but i didn't see any
points about increasing iq per se but
intelligence and that's
different and for the people in the chat
or people who are listening watching
once this is on uh
replay i i find that people are
extremely uncomfortable with the notion
of iq
and they like to point to steven j gould
gould who has a critique on iq but his
critique on iq was more about whether or
not iq measures something nebulous
called
intelligence and intelligence like i
mentioned is nebulous or bleary it's not
clear exactly what it is
people have different notions and iq
measures something extremely specific
and iq is correlated highly with
different outcomes in life
as well as the ability to learn quickly
whether or not in
well either way the whole point of that
is to ask did you
learn or did you come across any methods
to increase one's iq
there are obviously ways to decrease it
well if we pull
yes if we pull back the kimono about
what why that article exists there are
people who search
the term how to increase iq
i have i've just been i had been
thinking about it independently for a
long time because people on my youtube
channel ask me all the time how can i
increase my iq
but one day my seo came to me which is
for people who don't know internet stuff
is search engine optimization and or
he's a search engine optimization expert
he's on my team
and so i just call him my seo anyway
he says you should do this article on on
iq and i thought ah that's a bit risky a
little bit
you know not as you say not the most um
safe topic necessarily but people are
searching for it
my mission is to reach people who are
searching for things related to memory
so what the hell i'll write about this
and i pretty quickly in that article say
let's change the definition of iq and
then i talk about
goal oriented stuff so the answer is you
know
no i don't necessarily have any ways to
increase iq
but by the same token i think it's worth
the
hypothesis to say if we're going to
increase it what are the ways that we
could increase it
and that article is now still a first
draft
and i we tend to update these things
everything on the internet
is beta i mean video is a bit hard to do
after the fact
but in terms of articles and podcasts
you you're able to just see
can we actually get the people who are
searching for iq
with this i told my seo guy look i'm not
going to do it the way that you told me
to outline it i'm going to do it this
way
and we'll see what happens i haven't
asked them whether it made it to page
one or not
we're pretty good we have 80 20 rule
like everybody else
and get in terms of getting to page one
but i'm
fairly good at it with certain keywords
he throws at me
i don't know what we did with that one
but i thought it was worth a try
because people are searching for it and
what they mean
i think when they say when they put into
google
how to increase iq they mean how do i
get smarter
right and so in terms of how do you get
smarter
i think i have include not only have i
got theories and techniques and
strategies for people to do that
but i think i've got a proven track
record of it i mean we've got
lots of people who have passed exams
that they
didn't dream of passing before they
started to train their memory
and made advancements in learning
languages etc
i'd call that intelligence because if
you can figure out
how to set a goal how to
do what it takes to accomplish that goal
and then properly reward yourself once
it's done
with full modesty then
what else what else would that be other
than having increased your intelligence
i fully acknowledge that it's not
exactly directly addressing
that article uh directly addressing iq
as
the measured thing on those sorts of
tests that has to do with spatial
intelligence or spatial calculation
ability
and being able to match certain
dimensional things and then there's
verbal
all that sort of stuff but i think that
we could we could work on it and i think
that memory would be
one of the places that we need to focus
on and raw memory training
i mean it's only it's only 120 years or
something
since ebbinghaus started his very um
n equals one kind of memory experiments
in turn which is i don't know about that
what is this person's name edding house
ebbing house
ebbinghaus hermann ebbinghaus and he
wrote
it's in german uber desk deschnes which
is basically
about memory and what he had done
is he came up with the principles of
like the forgetting curve
and he had memorized a bunch of stuff
and he would just test
how long it was before he forgot it and
that led to
concepts like primacy effect and recency
effect serial positioning effect
all of which i mean if we're going to
just talk about intelligence in sort of
straight language
what else would you call intelligence
other than your ability to remember what
you learned
see it in context in real time be able
to juggle what people are saying
interact with them or whatever a test is
saying and so forth
and not be destroyed by a forgetting
curve
which is what a lot of people struggle
with within three seconds they'll forget
your name
within you know five days they'll forget
what they read
etc and they're struggling with that so
ebbinghaus was huge and it's we're
really just
at the beginning of memory as a as a
science as a study
and it has historical philosophical
biological chemical neural
chemical dimensions to it that's just
waiting to be
explored so what do you what do you say
about
the adaptive quality of forgetting so
for example
some people who have unbelievable
memories for
events in their lives like episodic
memory they
are often leading horrible lives you can
see
you can see there's a few documentaries
on this where they
remember exactly what they're eating 10
years ago on a certain day and the
weather and so on
and they they see
their natural penchant for memory as
being a curse
in a sense because they remember all
their mistakes and this one lady
said you know how you ruminate at night
so she was speaking to the camera how
you say
oh i wish i could have said this then
and so on so imagine doing that
for every conversation for the past 20
years
then i was watching i don't know you
probably
would know much you're probably correct
now as for
there's this person who apparently has
the highest iq in america now that's
like
who knows because iq at the extremely
high range
you can't actually test it in the way
that people think you can
whatever his name is chris langan you
know i'm sure chris langan said that
he doesn't have a great memory and that
what he thinks
intelligence is is the
proper selection of what you remember so
if you can remember a whole book
so what it matters like you mentioned
for your goals so what do you say to
that
about memories memory is great but at
the same time
your brain one's brain is set up to
forget for specific reasons so that
means your memory has to be matched with
with adaptive forgetting so it has to be
adaptive memory and doctor forgetting
so how do you balance that like what do
you say to someone who has an
obscene memory right well superior
autobiographical memory is a very
interesting topic
and the the you know the full decisions
about what it is and how it works aren't
out
but there are a couple of cases
where skeptics of superior
autobiographical memory have done some
research
and they have seen that there's a
commonality among some of these cases
because if it isn't a sort of savantism
that's involved there is an
ocd level of self rumination
and often journaling so i don't know if
you're if you're referring to jill price
but jill price
it was a highly publicized figure the
book is called the woman who can't
forget
which i think was ghost written for her
or you know with her um
but in any case it's it's an interesting
book to read but what the book doesn't
talk about but that was discovered by
some
people who are a little skeptical of
this is that she's an obsessive
journaler
right and um often rehearsing
again and again and again what was
journaled the day before
now i don't think that the obsessive
journaling accounts for all of this but
i think it
it's a clue to something that's going on
in some people
and it's interesting that it's
autobiographical memory
it's not clear that it's the uh episodic
that is as strong
um although obviously they blur
in any case i don't know but i don't
know that it's clear that they
have somehow lost adaptive forgetting in
ways that others haven't
i think it's maybe a little bit more
clear
that there's a commonal commonality in
terms of rumination
that is leading to exactly the things
that memory competitors do
or people who use memory techniques do
which is a kind of
forced ocd where you're rigging serial
positioning effect to give everything
primacy and recency so that you can
remember it
longer using what's called fond
restaurant effect which is you
exaggerate it
and so you can look at cases like jill
price and you know with all
do humility that i don't know or never
talk to her and nobody seen interviews
with her
but it seems like she's exaggerating a
lot of the events in her life
which would lead to them not only being
more memorable but causing
more suffering um and we i've done that
to myself you know and i think we've all
had that experience that sting of
something you said
and you can't just you just can't let it
go well
what is it that you can't let it go is
it because you constantly rehearse it
and
compound its value so that it shocks you
more and more and becomes more and more
painful or
is it i don't know it's not necessarily
clear
but to answer your question directly
forgetting is normal
it's sort of healthy but it's also not
necessarily the case that you have to
forget anything
you could work on it
but there will be a forgetting curve at
least that's what we see in the science
and i think we see it in
in our practical lives if you don't use
it you will lose it
and even english the years i lived in
germany
i started to experience what's called
linguistic de-skilling my english skills
went down
and i noticed them going back up after i
moved to
australia it was just just the strangest
thing but
that's interesting you know i wouldn't
say that my english is
is profoundly good in any respect
at all but it had gone down noticeably
and i noticed it
after living in an english-speaking
country again that it went back up
there was this one exercise you had
recently on your channel
maybe you've referenced it before but i
saw it in one of your most recent videos
about the alphabet and visualizing it on
a grid
yeah are you able to see all 26 letters
at once
in your mind's eye no but that's a good
question
so when we think about can you see 26
letters at once
what do we mean by seeing 26 letters at
once right
so if i if i think you mean what i think
you mean then the answer is no
but at the same time there is an image
of the alphabet
and i can see that yeah see mike is
doing it i don't think i even
did the entire exercise but what i
gathered from it
i can imagine that i could vaguely see
the entire alphabet
and that i can trick myself into
thinking i'm seeing the alphabet because
my eyes just like my eyes right now are
secating
around and i get an image of the hole
but i'm actually only seeing a part at
any point
i imagine that let's say i'm looking at
well what's around g
then i go around g and i see the plus or
minus around g maybe plus or minus two
plus or minus three
around g when i say plus or minus i mean
the letters and then i second down to z
and then i sub it up to
q and so on and i think that i'm seeing
all 26 letters but i'm not
so you're saying that the point of the
exercise isn't
to visualize all 26 at once nor is it
well
that's not the point of the exercise the
point of the exercise
is to help people begin to understand
what the memory tradition is
and how it's how and why
it working with what used to be called
the gematria is useful i mean it's still
called the commitria
but um a lot of memory techniques
involve understanding that language is
built from alphabet and alphabet
builds language and what we're doing
when we use memory techniques
is we're perceiving a sort of
fundamental oneness or sameness and
information
that is differentiated by symbols and
there's multiple levels of mental
imagery so when i just said
i can see the alphabet as a singular
thing i actually don't even mean that i
can see it
because seeing is the thing that eyes do
right
but the a notion that eyes
is an image that appears in my mind
right so
even the idea that eyes are a thing that
sees
is a mental image that has multiple
properties
right that is appearing as an image
inside of my own image
of my own consciousness i i don't
understand what i could do
i don't even know if i understand it
either because it's a kind of infinite
regress right
and earlier you mentioned something
about a oneness with regard to memory
what are you referring to there
well yesterday i met with my uh monthly
coaching group where we talk about
memory stuff and i gave them an exercise
which is
or a game we played which is i said a
sentence which was a white cat ate a
frog
and then the next student said a
sentence and then the next student said
a sentence and we all have to repeat the
sentence that the previous person said
that's great and i'm introducing intuit
numbers i'm introducing intuit
adjectives i'm introducing into it
and they are naturally also and when we
got to the end like everybody fails
quite quickly because it's quite hard
right
but um you know and somebody had
mentioned
uh peyton manning who i guess is a
football player
i'd never heard of this person before
but uh i used preston manning who i
think was the leader of the reform party
at some point in canadian political
history as my image for that
now when i what i described to them
after is one of the reasons why i
played the game better than they did is
because i don't see the information
different than they do they they think
oh my goodness now i have to account for
a verb
what image am i going to use for a verb
oh peyton manning is number one is what
one person one student said
now i have to think number one which is
somehow different than the name
uh peyton manning right and i just
i don't see it that way because i've
created this
set of tools that allows me to just make
it information as such
and there's a experience of oneness with
the information
because you're that fast in terms of
elaborative encoding it's called
so when you look at the kids who i mean
it's not even just kids but
just call them kids because they're
getting younger and younger in the
memory competitions
um they're memorizing decks of cards in
like 17 seconds 12 seconds
52 individual cards in order
with 100 accuracy there's a oneness
that's going on between
multiple layers of information order
suit
number perhaps they're even referring to
color in how they process
suits and there's
th this is happening because the mind
has been trained to disregard
distortion and just connect
in the moment but multi-layer
multi-layers of information all the same
the mind has been trained or their mind
because they were
memory champions or working toward being
that their mind has been trained or the
my
all of our minds are trained like that
well i don't know if we want to get into
non-duality
and uh the potential that it's just one
mind doing it
but let's just say for practice for
practical purposes somebody sat there
and
like an individual unit of consciousness
sat there
and trained the meat factory that is you
know
somehow producing that that and so the
person who didn't train that
isn't going to do it you know my best
time with cards is two minutes and 30
seconds
and i got bored and i'm just like not
going to get faster than that because
you know there's no practical benefit to
my life to be able to memorize faster in
two minutes and 30 seconds but i can
tell you
in that moment you're one with all the
things
it's it's like being in task positive
network or what uh mihai chiksen mihaiyu
calls uh
flow it's just flow but to get there
you have to annihilate the idea that
information is different
it's it's just it's just information and
you have the tools and you just
okay explain to me let's say there's a i
know that's fake
but that's what it feels like let's take
an ordinary person
or a typical member of the population
you pick someone from the street
and you say memorize these 10 cards
let's make it simple 10 cards they may
take a minute or so
and then they may get some wrong and
how are they trying to memorize and how
is that different
when one is thinking of the information
as
being of the same vellum or the same
cloth or the same
type like i i don't i've
like helped me through how i'm supposed
to understand that
i don't i'm so far removed from what a
normal person would do
quote unquote normal person that it's
hard for me to guess what that
experience is like but let me imagine it
they're probably thinking okay jack of
clubs
and then next comes queen of hearts
they may be repeating it aloud to
themselves as well yeah and then they're
trying to mentally juggle and
and then it was you know was it what was
it jack space would you
chug the clubs right they're already
getting jumbled up
whereas the trained person jack of clubs
is a cheetah and queen of hearts is a
bone
so now that she and i'm not going to
speak for all memory converters because
some of them do this differently
but this is the basics the cheetah is
now going to throw the bone
at whatever the symbol is for the next
card so let's say it's ace of spades so
they're going to
throw a bone at the uh frog right
so now that's gonna help person object
object action or is that different
person action object yeah
um they don't all do it exactly that way
but the idea is is that
if you have 52 cards to memorize you're
going to have a personal action object a
person action object person action
object typically
this is going to be layered out in a
memory palace and so
that's like uh a mat you know
prices was it prices right is the one
where they spin the wheel and then they
guess the words
i think that's wheel of fortune oh sorry
wheel of fortune yeah well price of
right
also has a wheel but yeah there's right
that's right bob barker versus pat sajak
um the
the whatever it is there's there's a
cell in
position probably the price's right
wheel is is a little bit better
sure because um i don't know it doesn't
matter the idea is that there's a cell
in space
and that cell is gonna yeah like a like
you know on the price of white wheel
that spins around
and it's got like 200 300 etc okay but
now imagine that you have one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
and in position one you're gonna have a
cheetah and then you just turn the wheel
and then in position two you're gonna
have a bone and then you turn the wheel
and in position three
you're gonna have a toad so that i can
now remember yeah i'm even just managing
my own memory right now i think
look at the transcript i said jack of
clubs queen of hearts and
is made right because yeah well i mean
i have a crap i have a bad memory if i
don't use these tools i forget the stuff
that's gone
you know um so but when i use these
things and i'm
and i'm well practiced then it's even
better um
because you know you can throw down and
say hey i'm gonna
compete for charity today and not walk
away completely embarrassed but actually
do
half as well as a guy who has two
guinness world records which i
think was quite something actually
especially given that i was hungover and
not feeling well in many regards but
that's what it is that's what you do and
you have to be one with it
you have to be so it's like a martial
art like you're you're not sitting there
if you're um engaged in in sparring or
in an actual combat heaven forbid you're
not thinking
oh kata this or whatever you're just
trained that this is coming in
and you're gonna fold it and put it into
place and you're gonna do it in a way
that it stays there your enemy doesn't
want to move after they've
confronted with you because you're just
zoom zoom zoom
and that's that's basically what i mean
by oneness you don't have time to think
about it
you don't have time to fret about it you
don't have time to hum and haw about it
this must translate to that and it must
do so in a way
that lasts for as long as you need it to
last
see when i think about what oneness
means i'm thinking
about being different ripples in the
field of consciousness and so on and all
that exists is
simply the sea of experience
when you're describing encoding
different
phenomenon like cards or whatever maybe
i i still don't see how it's won other
than what you've
alluded to which is it becoming
reflexive i don't see reflex
reflexes being or at least not conscious
deliberation
i don't see that as being the same as
one so when you say one i don't think
i'm understanding it correctly
let's say you have this these cards and
the regular person may
repeat the card over and over
in order they get to card number three
they go back to card number one no
number two number three number four okay
i got number four now let me go back one
two three four five okay i got those
cards
i see that as not being efficient
and but i don't see the oneness in in
the explanation that you gave
like what is the oneness you're
translating it down to cheetahs and to
bones and so on but there's no oneness
between cheetah and bones at least i
don't see so
do you mind helping well let's let's
look at the word oneness itself right
oneness is where when you're when you're
reflecting on oneness where is it
all around well where is that
like you're genuinely asking me to go
yeah i'm asking you
not because i'm interested in creating
radio silence but if you really think
about it
where is the concept of oneness and then
you say well it's all around but then
where is the concept of all around
and then i'm just go it's just going to
be an infinite regress and the answer is
i have no idea because right now kurt is
appearing in me
right and you're you're for i don't know
you're in toronto what's toronto well
toronto is appearing in me
and everything's just appearing right
now in me and i assume it's appearing in
you right
so if there's a oneness and you and i
are connecting right now we're having a
conversation
hopefully it's a good one for you i'm
having fun myself and so forth the
oneness is right now it's right here
this is it
right we can call it oneness we can say
there's a reflect
the reflection this a recursion that
yadda yadda whatever we're doing we're
just piling on more words
and those words are coming into this
space right now
right and if you're going to recall back
to a conversation later
well then something about that lasted
when did it last
where did it last well right now it's in
this
whatever we call this we can just pile
on more words
but the very idea that oneness is
defined differently by you
has only so much difference because we
are now communicating about that
difference which requires a sameness it
requires a oneness
in order for it to even happen so when
we're memorizing cards or whatever it is
that we're doing
we are experiencing a fundamental
oneness
that information appears in us and we
have tools
to make that appearance so robust
that it lasts to repeat reappear in us
later
it's a i think we get into semantics
when we try to get into what oneness
means because oneness
it only means by virtue of it being in
the field
that is perceiving the very concept of
meaning itself
and i feel like i'm like on the verge of
just spouting endless depoties that
sound making me sound like a
the kind of person i don't actually want
to sound like but
what what what else can you say you know
this is the this is the problem of
discussing things like spirituality
and yeah and yadda yadda because you
just end up saying
endless deepities but at the same time
sorry what is that deputies
this is this is like in the atheist
community uh
a weapon that they use uh oh i didn't
know that i know
yeah well whoo-hoo is is another one
right
but like it's a deputy basically is
something
that sounds really profound and so forth
but actually isn't because
to unspool it you only end up
you know pulling putting more thread
into the basket rather than less
and uh i'm very deeply concerned about
that because i study sanskrit
and i look at these ancient traditions
and when i when i
get through the departies so to speak
what i find is that actually they're
like
they're more atheist than anything i've
ever seen in my life i started to call
it
uber atheist you know i thought i used
to be an atheist but damn
like in in some of these ancient texts
why don't you take us through some of or
just take us through your journey from
atheism to i don't know what you would
call yourself now but probably not
atheists so let's just say not
uber atheist i like uber atheist okay
especially because uber has some uh
nuances in german
and also for the people listening
anthony has a website do you mind
telling people where they can find out
more about you not that we're ending but
just so that people can
make note of it um
magneticmemorymethod.com
and hey anthony you may not know this
but when i was searching your name in my
inbox
i wanted to make sure that i sent you
all the correct information i noticed i
had
20 emails from you from before i'm like
from 2019 or 2018
and oh it turns out that i signed up for
your
i signed up for your newsletter quite
some time ago
and i had forgotten so that's pretty
cool i
probably i wasn't as memorable as i
hoped
well i don't recall why i did that i'm
i'm not sure but anyway well in the
great chaos uh
and vastness of the internet it often
proves to not be as big as it seems
so there's this guy who his name is
jonathan
i want you all to know that anthony
mativier responds promptly
personally and repeatedly to questions
about this talk
if you contact him via his website i've
corresponded with him twice today
actually so just so people know people
in the chat people who are listening
you can contact anthony anthony responds
i don't know at least
in my experience respond with quite
detailed
messages like you care and i don't know
where you get the time to do so
but if people do have questions they can
easily contact you
and you'll you're more than likely to
respond
where do you get the time and the
inclination to do this
well i'll show you my secret weapon if
you like
this enables me to type about three
times faster than most humans can
even imagine typing it's a special
keyboard what is it
what the heck is that so this is called
a safe type keyboard
and it has the keys vertical and split
on both sides
so uh that reduces strain on your wrists
and uh you type like this and uh so
yeah i'm also a typing addict so yeah if
i
answer in detail it is because i care
but i'm also you know
doing my own dopamine addiction
management at some level
um i haven't seen that keyboard before
do you mind giving me
it's called a display of how you would
type
without actually typing yeah um some
chaos may go on on my other
computer here but i would just say you
know hi
kurt how are you
then you know if i if i'm in an actual
position
at my stand-up desk so it just looks
like that
and if you um you know if you if you can
do
touch typing i guess it's called where
you're not looking
by the way you can train yourself
because this these people who came up
with this are genius
it has mirrors my mirrors broke off a
long time ago but you have these mirrors
that come out
and um that can help you train to be
able to
to see the keys and you know some of the
numbers can be kind of tricky but in the
middle there's a number pad
so it's it's great what's that called
it's called safe type safe and i believe
that's their url but they haven't
updated their site in forever
uh i think you can get them through
amazon and whatnot
so we're going through your journey from
atheism to whatever you are now
right right uber atheist um
well it's a long story as many stories
are but
here i have my i've been drinking from
my waking up cup
from the sam harris podcast back when it
was called waking up and uh
i i guess somehow he was part of
being like a militant atheist because
you know when i went to do my phd i have
to do this like language thing so i
picked biblical hebrew
and why i picked biblic biblical hebrew
as opposed to any other of the many
possible languages that you could
work on was because i wanted to have
revenge on my mother i was a very angry
person about having been brought up in
the church and i had a feeling that if i
could read for myself what the bible
says
then i would just have endless toys to
play with during
all kinds of conversations um and you
know it turns out that you do have
endless toys
when you can read a bit of biblical
hebrew to play with but uh
i've gotten a lot of peace with that and
i don't even use it
uh anymore but sam harris one day
driving through the united states
listening to npr and he says
what is this word atheist all about
anyway we don't call people who don't
believe in astrology
non-astrologists so it's kind of like a
silly thing
and that kind of hooked me because i
like that you know
i like to cut through the chase and get
at what's going
going on here and really there's no such
thing as atheism
there's there should be no need for it
it's not an ism in the same way in logic
it's a bad choice to call um para
consistencies
diet diet what is it called dialectism
right because it's not a belief
dialecticism is not a belief in anything
it's just noticing
that there are sometimes para
consistencies you're not
and it's not ism but somehow they chose
the ism
so atheism and me being called an
atheist
is already problematic from when i quote
unquote got into it
right but i was quite militant about it
and because i'm a bit of a theatrical
person
sometimes you know if you're not
part of the solution you're part of the
problem and i saw for a long time
religion religious belief irrational
things as part of the problem
and that somewhat hasn't changed
but it has softened to
also look at counter examples counter
arguments and then realize
wait a second evolution has forwarded
this
for a very long time and if anything
it's getting stronger
and you know i did a lot of film studies
etc etc and it just sort of doesn't make
sense to be
so black and white you're either for the
science or you're against it kind of
thing and studying sanskrit
really changed or deepened my idea and
understanding of what science is anyway
in terms of making hypothetical claims
providing evidence for and against
things to
either bolster them at least for a time
or discredit them but also at least for
a time
and then just thinking about n equals
one as a
as a scientific proposition itself which
is
whether solipsism is real or a problem
or not is what we're forced to do
we are scientific beings and then you
know it reminded me a lot of nietzsche
and i had a great professor uh
at european graduate school when i did
an m.a there named fred alfors who was
the chair of the nietzsche studies
program there
and he had pointed out nietzsche does
not mean god is dead
nietzsche means that if that's the way
you're gonna worship your god
he may as well be dead and
i think that that nuance and and you see
it in nietzsche
when you when you read it with that in
mind that nuance makes all the
difference in the world
so that's kind of the journey there and
something about studying you know
sanskrit and meditating with
long-form memorization so that you not
only understand it but you then become
depre
you come to practice it so you remind
yourself of the principles of
non-duality
you remind yourself of of flow because
your procedural memory is so highly
trained to do it
then yeah i mean
it's just more words atheism stuff it's
just more words appearing in
consciousness and that the question
really is
what do you do with that moment do you
enjoy the ride or don't you uh
do you show up at your best to help
others
or don't you that kind of stuff is
how does sanskrit help
don't know that it does uh although
there there may be something
to the sanskrit itself i don't know um
so gary weber who i read a lot of his
books
he mentions he just sort of like throws
this away as a comment in
happiness beyond thought that there may
be something about
where the tongue touches the mouth with
certain languages
that creates certain things in the
default mode network of the brain or the
task positive network of the brain
that can lead one to
you know the experience of a quote
unquote deeper state of consciousness
but really how can if you have
consciousness how could it really be
deeper
than anything else i don't know uh
unless you are manu you're participating
in the manufacture of that
which i think you can do without
self-delusion um
but at the end of the day it's not clear
to me that it has to be sanskrit
the thing is is that the sanskrit that
i've studied encodes certain messages
and so there's benefits to singing that
we know
uh you know there's studies that show
that your
your brain is producing healing
chemicals when you sing
there's benefits to having certain
messages in your mind as opposed to
other ones
and because i use a memory palace to do
all of this
there's benefits to that as well dr tim
dalglish has done studies on using
memory palaces
to help people with depression and with
ptsd that has shown great results
so i don't know that it has to be
sanskrit but i think that
there's possibly something about the way
the tongue touches the mouth
that maybe has some benefits and there's
i think there's definitely a message
benefit even though
it's pretty brutal in its consequences
in its implications
uh if you're not ready for it so to
speak
is there an exercise you can take me
through
now almost live like
well wim hof obviously has the wim hof
exercises that one can do
is there one obviously would have to be
for uh
well it doesn't have to be but i imagine
it would be great if it was for a
particular purpose like let's say
you were training me right now to get
into a state where i can memorize the
deck of cards and
under a minute that's not going to
happen at least not right now
and it may take years to do that but is
there something else that
you can is there some exercise you can
take me through maybe one that involves
sanskrit because
i i don't know any sanskrit i don't know
how
i i haven't said a single word of
sanskrit
consciously and i'm curious as to how
the pronunciation
of a particular word may impact my
consciousness in a different manner
um yeah well we could we could cook
something up
yeah yeah let's do it if you don't mind
anything since you mentioned it though
it wouldn't take you years to memorize a
deck of cards i mean i've never done it
under a minute but
two minutes and 30 seconds did not take
me years it wouldn't take you that long
uh josh iv who wrote the very famous
book moonwalking with einstein i think
it was six months
before he was often in competitive mode
uh and did quite well
so it doesn't have to take that long
yeah deck of cards was not necessarily
the high order goal that a lot of people
i was i was being facetious right right
but in any case if you if you wanted to
uh boost up memorizing sanskrit then
within a weekend you would have to how
about i'll be able to memorize sanskrit
how about this anthony if you don't mind
is there a way
is there some exercise you can take me
through right now that would put my mind
that would calm me
not that i have a problem with being not
that i'm not calm right now speaking to
you but i'm
but i'm i'm curious yeah so a very
simple one is
is called uh kirtan kriya which is you
take your hands like this
and you go satan
[Music]
apparently in the science you've got to
do this like for two and a half minutes
or three minutes or something okay to
start to get a benefit and i have to say
it aloud or it can say to my head
i think you could do both okay uh
now there's you know some ideas that
those
syllables mean something i really don't
know whether they mean something or not
and i
i don't i don't care but the the
research
shows that this improves memory
concentration and so forth
and we can do it together for as long as
you want um
but if you want to get more benefit from
it you don't have to just go
repetitively
skip the syllables now what does that do
for you well that starts to
train you in how memory techniques work
in terms of giving
premises and recency you through serial
positioning effect
to different quote-unquote stations in
space
and that includes concentration a lot
because then it becomes a bit of a game
that's challenging
have you experimented at all with dual
and back yeah and you know those things
relate to these kinds of exercises
what i like about this as opposed to
those softwares that people put together
is it's in your hands your you're
producing it
yourself which creates a bit more of a
challenge it also creates more
frustration at some level
but if you can show up to balance that
curve between challenge and frustration
i think you get more benefits out of it
because you're improving the very field
of your conscious experience
by using the field itself without
external reference
even if what i'm suggesting to you is
externally referenced
okay so i'm gonna try this right now if
i make a fool of myself just please
forgive me
so i'm going to i'm going to play around
with this
and i know this may be boring to you for
a minute or so but is it all right if i
do this yeah please it's not boring to
me at all
okay
now what i'm doing right now is
almost as if i'm playing my own game in
my head where i'm
i'm choosing i'm trying to choose
randomly obviously you can't
manufacture your own randomness but as
randomly as i can
choose a different syllable for a
different
finger and to try to remember that for
the duration of the full saturn
now is that the is that the correct way
or am i just
ruining the exercise how should i be
doing this essentially
well it comes back to what you said like
let's have a goal so if we have a goal
then we can think about whether
the technique is correct for getting to
that goal or not but
true playing around and experimenting is
is great um
in in what i have tried to do maybe we
should talk about what i tried to do
yeah sure you know like what do you what
are your daily practices how about we
get to that that's a question i ask
everyone
in right in the exordium but i didn't
ask you and i apologize so what are your
daily rituals what are your practices
these practices are all oriented towards
a specific goal
which is can you silence your mind can
you experience
complete mental silence and so the
practice is there
and this is pretty much daily i'm quite
good but nobody's
i i don't think anybody's 100 but i'm
pretty close
every day i recite what is a growing
body of
sanskrit verses that i've memorized
and i stretch do a little bit of you
know
kind of like yoga stuff uh and
do a bit of silent meditation do some
walking do some journaling
and then i do what in some of these
traditions they call karma yoga which is
just to
do my work and let go of the outcome
literally
practicing letting go of the outcome you
know because thoughts will arise like oh
i hope this is a successful day
etc i hope that this helps that person
or if only this number was higher
yeah yeah yeah you know all this vanity
metrics that you get into when you're
on the internet and just let it go
practice letting go letting go letting
go
so basically my ritual is to just do
that all day long
but i premise it or preface it and
premise it upon
daily recitation of what i memorize not
every day but
often memorizing another piece to learn
more about the philosophy to have a
longer meditation
so that it incrementally grows in time
and uh
just to reflect upon the practice itself
that's that's basically it do you mind
giving me some
tips on
letting go and calming one's mind
yeah uh i could give lots of tips uh
i think the the interesting thing for me
about it
and this is the tip is to try to
to try to realize that you you have a
mind that allows you to
be aware that you have a mind and
everything that's coming into
consciousness
is the mind is that mind it is that
thing
that you are wrestling with right
so this kind of comes back to oneness
and what is non-duality really
right is nonduality sitting around and
like
trying to stop your mind and have
silence all the time or whatever which i
think is a fun goal
i i do work on it i have had these
experiences of total silence
but the real tip is is just to be able
to be in a position
where you just deal with whatever comes
period
right and so you know as much as i've
practiced over the years
something will still happen and i'll get
pissed off and then just be able to
wait this is a thing that's appearing in
this field of consciousness
and then just deal with it work with it
yeah and just
you know you know a lot of people will
say label it but then
i think you go deeper or deeper you just
say
i'm you realize you're even labeling the
thing and then you're
why are you doing it well because you
have this fantasy that some strategy of
labeling
is going to now dissolve or neutralize
the anger whereas
there's also the realization of the idea
that doing something in response to the
label
you know is then going to have this
magic effect i see i think
really what you are doing i'm trying to
do is be more aware
of this idea that there's magic that you
could somehow change
whatever your biology is doing as
opposed to having strategies
to just be with the biology you know
like eckhart tolle would say beyond name
and form
you know just even the guy who shows up
to label the experience
as if the labeling is somehow going to
do something
you're now experiencing that as yet
another thing that is appearing in this
field of consciousness
okay so working on that practice is the
biggest tip
how do you do that well you just get
started and you keep practicing
and you set up the game so that your
mind yourself reminds you and that's
procedural memory
how do you do that well i would highly
recommend memorizing some text
that is written for that precise purpose
and do it daily and even throughout the
day
so that instead of oh now i'm going to
label angry and then that's going to
like help me
it set instead of that you have
something else
which is more like what i talked about
in the ted talks are these thoughts
useful
how do they behave there's 30 or there's
28 more questions that you can ask
and they're very useful i have about 28
questions right now
so i'll pick one or two of them one of
them is
when you mention how do i how does how
do these thoughts behave that one
actually isn't useful for me the first
one is
i actually like that first one i used it
last night are these thoughts useful but
then
how do i how do these thoughts behave i
don't know
why this is but for whatever reason that
actually brings me into more
introspection
and makes me observe the thoughts and
watch how they flow and relate to one
another rather than
an elimination of the thoughts or a
calmness of the mind
it's more like that's helping me think
about thoughts
which is still thinking so i like the
first one i didn't find the second one
helpful but
i i probably don't have the same idea as
to what you have when you say
how do these thoughts behave maybe i'm
thinking of it differently forget about
that we're going to put it to the side
and i can come back to that
what you mentioned earlier was that
let's imagine there's irritation
annoyance
anger fear boredom these let's
let's imagine we don't want those now
you're saying
kurt if you go into it thinking i don't
want this so let me apply some technique
to eliminate it
that itself is well
it's still an an object in consciousness
it's still a
want and thus you're not getting to the
core of the issue
instead you should
the elimination of boredom or anxiety or
fear or anger
is more the result of some other process
and but if you try to just eliminate it
then you're going about it incorrectly
is that correct or is that a name
no i just would would say that the
the observation would then be correct
according to what
according to to whom and to who is it
that the very notion of correctness
appears so this is where it can
sound like super frustrating but in a
lot of these non-duality things it's
just like this is where your foucault
comes out
maybe maybe because foucault and
non-duality are not that different
not that different right what is
foucault saying at least in crime
or discipline and punish um
these uh peripraxies and freudian slips
are always fascinating
if you want to indulge in being
fascinated by
but okay which i do sometimes but anyway
the point is
you know foucault is talking about a
process by which
you internalize the surveillance
so that the surveillance doesn't even
have to exist right
you just come let me stop you there okay
let me think about that
internalize the surveillance so that the
surveillance doesn't exist
it doesn't doesn't have to it doesn't
have to exist
that subtlety matters yeah do you mind
explaining what that means so
internalize the surveillance first let's
take it right there so what is the
surveillance
well we're now like playing a game here
where foucault is now suddenly a
a a great sage but um
i think that it's a i think it's a good
a analogy
because at least as i understand
discipline and punish
he's saying that you know the the
panopticon is so constructed
that the cameras don't have to be real
but the
prisoner has internalized the image of
the camera
to such an extent that they behave as if
it was real and they behave in such a
way that they monitor their own
behavior as if the consequences of the
camera that may or may not be real
is real and those consequences are real
so
if we translate that to the idea of
non-duality and the spiritual
or philosophical state of being able to
manage yourself
to such an extent that you are free and
peaceful and satwik as they say
in uh sanskrit which is just you know
bliss
uh well then that yeah
it's s-a-t-t-v-i-c uh so i guess
i'm not a sanskritis but i guess if
you're like really hardcore
whatever a lot of them
well i mean like german takes the w's
and making it into a v
yeah i mean i guess i guess i guess so
um uh wittgenstein you're right yeah
um uh in any case
i think i think it's an interesting way
to think about it because
if you read someone like shinzen young's
the science of enlightenment which is a
great book
he basically says do all the stuff
meditate etc
but the minute you think that you're
somehow
in a blissful state or whatever that's
the minute that you say
to whom is this actually occurring well
who is it that thinks oh now this is
bliss
right that's what you're after you're
after
the image that thinks it is experiencing
the image as if it's somehow different
than the image that it's experiencing
right okay and so now if we go back to
the panopticon thing
the goal of the surveillance state is to
make it that that person is so connected
with the idea of surveillance
that the surveillance doesn't even have
to exist they are just obedient power
has conducted the conduct of others to
such an extent
that they obey even in the absence of
something to monitor this and shenzhen
young is essentially saying
that true non-dual experience has
has something exactly like that you no
longer are sitting there thinking i'm
blissful or i'm not blissful or yadda
yadda
you are now just so one with whatever is
happening
that you are what is happening you don't
sit there and monitor
it you don't have the this idea that you
know oh this is an image that's
appearing in me
and the image now has multiple images
inside of it no no this has all just
disappeared
it is now just happening without
commentary
right because you now know
that you are it the the sanskrit tatwa
masih you are that
that's two thoughts occur to me anthony
when i hear that
one is an objection
one is how do i know this is not i'm not
fighting dory
it's just intellectual curiosity how
does one know that the
feeling of the screen or is the
perceiver and the perceived
being wanted the same how does one know
that that itself is not an illusion
in the same way that we're so deluded on
a regular basis in our
everyday life is to thinking that
there's that distinction and then one
says well
you can get to a state where that's
blurred and it's all one and you no
longer have that
distancing it's all just one well how
does one
know that that itself is not an illusion
that's question number one i'm going to
get back to that don't worry i'll
delineate these again then question
number two
was was about the point of it
sometimes when i hear people in the
non-duality community speak
nothing against nonduality i think i may
be on the route to becoming a
non-dualist
i don't know i don't know as i explore
this podcast more and more
i'm getting pulled in so many directions
that i'm becoming both a dualist a
pluralist and a
modest at the same time it's
if that's the point that's the point
right because if you really get into
this
the answer to the question is another
question to whom
is the very question appearing right and
from a non-dualist perspective
the question is appearing to us right
now as we're connected in this one
moment
we are it's irrelevant whether there's a
god or there isn't a god it's irrelevant
whether there's duality or non-duality
or all that sort of stuff
this is it right and five minutes ago
was it
five minutes from now well what is five
minutes from now five minutes from now
is an image that's appearing to us
right now as we converge upon then
yeah so i know it's frustrating but
that's basically what they're trying to
get at
that was that i find insightful which is
the
understanding that the future itself the
concept of the future itself is another
content in consciousness
and all that you have our contents in
consciousness including the concept of
time including the concepts including
the concept
of having anything including the concept
of having including the concept
of consciousness itself so well that one
it's it's far too
meta for me to experience during this
conversation
that one i imagine i would need to close
my eyes because i'm not as trained as
you i would need to close my eyes for
about 10 minutes to get to a state where
i can
where i can understand that at an
intuitive level or i can experience it
rather than
try to intellectually understand it so
let's forget about that the first
question
my objection is let's not forget about
that because that's the point
it's not about training or experience or
anything like that if you are conscious
you are conscious period whether you've
trained it or not
so the idea that i have more
consciousness than you or
the idea that some dude sitting in a
cave has more because he's meditated
for way longer than we have and he's
memorized way more sanskrit
has more consciousness than you or i do
no
no that that's that's what we're trying
to eliminate or at least that's what the
i find the authentic teachers of this
tradition is trying to eliminate
that idea that there's somehow any sort
of level
or difference or this that or the other
thing you can close your eyes you cannot
close your eyes it's all just appearing
in consciousness as it is now
and as consciousness is now you can't
take anything away from it you can't cut
it
you can't divide it you can't this that
or the other thing because
what would that mean right it's just
endless
stacking on of trying to get at the
thing that is producing the thing that
you're
you know i i unders i don't understand
sorry i understand it at intellectual
level what i mean
to say and i know that there's an
absolute difference between
understanding it
it's at an abstract cognitive level
versus embodying it or feeling it
now you may say that that's also not a
distinction that needs to be made but i
when i say that what i mean to say is
there is
absolutely a difference between trying
to
explicate what love is and define in
terms of oxytocin and understanding in
terms of its biochemical interactions
and feeling love those are absolutely
different so what i'm saying is
perhaps during this conversation i make
it get to the point where i can
intellectually
understand the ideas of non-duality but
i don't think i can
feel it maybe i can and i would love to
maybe we can get through some exercise i
don't think i can feel it during this
conversation though as you
though unlike some of the spiritual
leaders which would say that
the intellectualization of
some of these spiritual concepts
actually removes you from where you
should be i don't know if that's the
case
because i found what you said about the
future being encapsulated in the present
moment too
to be insightful and that actually helps
me i can imagine that helps me
later when i'm meditating or trying to
feel as if
i'm one or as if there's nothing else
beside
besides my feelings
getting back to what i was saying the
there's number one which is the illusion
how do you know that
the oneness itself isn't an illusion
i've always wondered this when sam
harris and many others say well the eye
is an illusion it's a persistent
illusion well how do you know the
the idea that the eye is an illusion
isn't itself an illusion
okay so that so that's one we can
explore we'll get back
we'll get back to that number two is
when you mentioned about quantifying
consciousness
and relating it between different people
like you said
you're not more conscious or you don't
have more consciousness than i do and
and someone in a cave who's a prodigious
meditator doesn't so and so on
okay well that's interesting then it
made me wonder
well what about zero consciousness is
there such
uh is there such a thing a concept
an existence of zero consciousness we're
going to explore that
i'm just giving you the table of
contents right now right and then number
three what i wanted to know was what's
the point
so that's the big question right the
pregnancy
because some of these people that are
more spiritual non-dualist types would
say
look how little fear i have look how
little look how calm and equinimitable i
am
but then the point is not
imperturbableness it's not to pursue
that
so then i'm wondering well what is the
point what is the point then they're
like there is no point okay so then why
should i be like you you don't have to
be like me
okay well what's the point of wha what
am i to do
okay so those are the three right we
have the illusion
how do i know that the oneness isn't an
illusion number two is is there such a
thing as zero consciousness number three
what is the point let's tackle them one
by one is that okay
well which one you want to start with
let's start with number one so how do
how does one know that the illusion
sorry how does one know that
this oneness itself isn't an illusion
now i'm going to change my headphones
because this one's
about to die all right and i'll get a
sip of water
i've been doing this
anthony i've been doing this all day but
this is energizing me so
don't worry hold on i can't hear you i
guess i
okay hello hello hello hello hello
see if the people in the chat are still
here and how many people there are and
if they have any pressing questions as
well
thank you how are you enjoying this is
it all right for you
anthony you're asking that to me or is
it the chat yeah
yeah you you uh
yeah i'm having lots of fun um but i i
sort of am aware that
this can get into like a kind of
intellectual noodling that
it is the question of always what is the
point and i think that a lot of the
point
that we get to is that some of us just
really enjoy this kind of stuff
and others you know uh haven't come to
experience this flavor of intellectual
jazz but uh
in terms of knowing whether the illusion
is an illusion
or it isn't i don't know that we get to
know and
that's that's the question of hard
solipsism
versus soft solipsism or
no solipsism and i think most people who
think about this agree that
the threat of hard solipsism whether
you're in a spiritual
tradition or not can lead to nihilism
uh it's it's almost you you'd be kind of
strange if you didn't go through
nihilism
as a result of this these thought
processes if only for a time
and in the spiritual world they often
call that the dark knight of the soul
you know because you can't know you
can't know whether it's an illusion or
not
uh what are they calling the dark knight
nihilism or something else
well i'm drawing a parallel and it may
not be in the same way that foucault's
panopticon is is not exactly a great
perfect analogy for
non-duality um this is not a great
perfect fit either but i think that in
hard solipsism there's a parallel to be
made with what happens in dark night of
the soul
because if you can't solve the problem
if you can't really figure out
how do i know whether this is an
illusion or not then you know
nihilism is the kind of direct
consequence of that because then so what
what is the purpose who cares look at
guys like zizek i i like zizek i had him
as a professor at european graduates oh
did you that's pretty cool
the guy seems to me like the joker of of
um
philosophy right like he he's just so
willing to make jokes about lenin this
and off to the gulag to you that
and it's just like
pouring out endless things that just you
can't really follow the thread
and i think that that's the point he's a
performative philosopher
who is essentially saying
in a zen-like kind of way good luck
figure out my co-ans because they're
just going to lead you
to the conclusion that i never tried to
make sense
what would it mean to make sense right
sense is a thing that's appearing right
now here
there if i said something five minutes
ago and you're holding me to this now
well then you're obviously a fellow
logos interest this
and off to the google active you know
like it's just it's complete
what the heck right and i think it's
done on purpose
you know and lacan who she is a disciple
of
lecon said that that's what the khan
said to do
he's like this is highly performative
you want to create a master slave
relationship between yourself and the
analyzand and you know
in order to play the master slave you've
got to pivot you've got to turn
and you've got to turn in ways that are
convenient to the moment convenient to
whatever is happening and that's what
shiite just does
and he does it large scale in front of
lots and lots of people
and it's never going to come to a point
because it's too zen
in its nature it's too master slave
relationship in his nature
to have a point because there isn't one
right is there something wrong with the
master slave relationship
uh in the con uh i the reason why i'm
saying this is because
it seems like some of the jumping off
point is to say that
door one or door two door one would lead
you to a master slave relationship
master slave is wrong so therefore door
two is the option i don't know if
i'm understanding that correctly but i
do hear that in la con and
and i don't know much about g-shack
other than
he's inscrutable to me and i need to pay
attention some more because i would love
to talk to him for this podcast
can't seem to get a hold of him though
either way i would love to talk to him
and i'm curious is there something
to be avoided about this master slave
relationship
and is there something to be is is it
laudable so
is it both to be avoided to be lauded
i don't know at the end of the day but
what i do know is that
that idea that you would willfully take
on a potentially destructive viewpoint
has has a it's a flavor in psychology
like if you look at
anti-psychiatry with thomas zazz and all
that sort of stuff
it's very difficult because basically
psychoanalysis i i should rather say
but i think zaz was anti-psychiatry was
the term that he used there
but i mean i went through psychoanalysis
myself so i'm not
just sort of like jamming on it out of
nowhere but the guy that i went through
psychoanalysis with
he was much more freudian in the sense
of creating a symbolic father figure
uh and that symbolic figure needed
a certain amount of symbolic behavior on
my part in order for it to function
as the symbolic father right in the
kanyen terms this would be big s over
little s
and in the g x terms this would be the
big other
sort of thing now the difference is is
that
lacan will be like a joker just like
throwing stuff
out like exp wild experiments because
knowing you're gonna die
zero sum game so you know if you're
going to be lost in fantasy
you'd better learn earlier that the
fantasy is often a lot more pleasurable
than the reality
and you you know build some filters that
help you figure that out
and i'll just play whatever role you
need me to play in this moment
no truth because what would truth mean
truth is just the thing that's appearing
in you now
you're always stuck in the now you're
going to make decisions based on
biological
imperatives etc etc so we'll just play a
game you and i
i'll be the master according to your
position as a slave right now i think
that that's
not great at the end of the day if you
ask me personally
but it's there it's in the world right
it's a flavor and
uh some people adopt it for whatever
reasons and
i think that people who are psycho
psychoanalyzed by lacan or inulikanian
thread they're much more likely to wind
up like a zigzag figure
which is a little bit wild unhinged
shooting from the hip
but very aware that that's exactly what
they're doing and
knowing that or thinking that part of
their healing
is precisely because that that's the way
they're operating right
because that was that's what it means to
be fully psychoanalyzed in the lacanian
sense
okay in the sense that i was
psychoanalyzed this is a little bit
different
slavoy you think that he's aware
that he isn't making sense to the
regular person or to the standard
observer
i feel confident that i can make that uh
statement because he himself has talked
about zen
a lot right and so you can read books
or the this is in interviews with him
published interviews and books
where he reflects on zen its role in
both both lacanian psycho analysis in in
dairy diet okay so let's imagine he's
doing that
i don't i don't have any objections to
that let's imagine he's doing that
and the reason he's doing that is
because it's healing in some manner or
because why
that i don't know you gotta ask him
because you mentioned healing just
a second ago you mentioned that through
this process of
of critiquing it all or showing that
it's all
not foolish but that it's all a joke in
some manner that that
heals well it can heal i mean that's
that's the thing in in the
psychoanalytic frame
it's thought that just something about
the psychoanalytic frame itself is
healing
or even just a therapeutic frame the
very symbolic
act of entering a theater in which
healing is said to occur
is supposedly going to be healing at
some level now obviously this is not the
case but that's part of the
uh or it doesn't have to be the case
because you know the theater of being in
a symbolic healing situation they can
still give you a drug that causes you to
jump off a bridge you know because
that's what the consequence of some
drugs do
um so you know i find it quite dangerous
and quite strange and by the way
i'm just uh
saying what i think i don't know that
these things are true uh necessarily
about g jack and i have spent a lot of
time in a room with him
so it's partly uh yeah i witnessed it
when is
the reason i was asking was only because
it sounds like lacan
well lecon i believe is a post-modernist
i don't even know what post-modernism
means you know i do but i don't
yeah yeah okay in the sense that he
doesn't believe that there are any
truths
no i don't think that that's that's what
i would say
i think okay so my take on all of this
is that post-modernism is a very weird
word
that somehow has take been taken from
art and then been applied to what's
called post-structuralism i don't know
if i'm correct about that
but i find it very strange to hear
anybody being called a postmodernist
even though i do know that people use it
that way i just don't know why because
post-modernism is like when you put red
on a wall and then you say
that's going to cause you to reflect on
all sorts of things about the nature of
art because
you know it's a reference to redness as
such and oh yeah
it looks fine by me that sounds like a
great mental
exercise and it is post-modern because
modernism painted in a particular way
yeah you correctly pointed out when you
watched the documentary better left
unsaid as a little plug
better left and said as a documentary i
was directing
thank you thank you i appreciate it
about the extreme left what makes the
extreme left extreme and then
we touch on the right as well you can
watch that
better left unsaid film.com when i sent
it to you you correctly pointed out that
modernism is different than modernity
and i
conflated those two in the film that was
slightly
well it was both an accident then on
purpose the reason
it's an accident was just because i made
that mistake and then the reason it's on
purpose
is that that's how people use the term
and so that's why i put a little
subtitle at the bottom and i said
when i say modernism i mean modernity
which is
the philosophical strain that comes up
after in the after the enlightenment or
that precipitated the enlightenment
okay anyway now that you have that yes
you're making a difference a distinction
between the artistic postmodernism and
the philosophical
well i think it's important because if
there's one thing that these
post-modernists have in common is that
they wildly throw around words
and they just use them in in way they
like recast words
and whether they're right or wrong to do
so i don't i can't be the judge of that
but it is it is exactly that sort of
being the joker just
throwing stuff out there and you know
not really having
some sort of compass or or foundation to
which all these things point
and just playing a wild game and so
truth it's not i don't think it's the
case that they don't think truth exists
it's just factuality is contingent
and that is the premise of science right
it is factual based on evidence
but that is contingent upon its
falsifiability
and the appearance of new evidence right
so
often in the atheist world you'll hear
people say well the time to believe in
something is when there's evidence that
substantiates the claim
sufficient to us believing in it but
that
in itself kind of folds in on itself
given what science is because science is
itself
contingent upon not only falsifiability
but
the idea that we will test and re-test
and continue to build the profile so to
speak
and mathematically and this is where the
quote-unquote post-modernism
modernist people go a little bit wild
because they're like yeah mathematically
exponentially everything is completely
you know
going to be uh unproven because the
burden of evidence will
or whatever right like they just play
these kinds of exponential games
and they do that with language itself so
language exponentially is going to fall
apart
because it is contingent on the present
use
our use right now and words are going to
change over time etc
at least that's how i understand a lot
of that stuff so it's not that truth
doesn't exist it's just that truth
is often contingent upon its use which
is
the problem with fake news which we see
all the time
you know uh is is that the truth is just
constantly being thrown out and used
in a utilitarian sort of way in order to
achieve a short-term goal
that then has these long-term
ramifications and then can be
easily rewritten because the container
is language which is itself already so
malleable
right images are so malleable uh
and now we're seeing this whatever those
words and images that are stored
in this or that data bank uh or database
can also just be either erased or you
can be prevented from being able to
visit it at all
right which is um very risky and
dangerous
and and sad and strange but
you know that that does cause us to
reflect on what is true and what could
be true
especially when we acknowledge that
the hypothetical claims that we make
about reality are contingent upon
evidence that either confirms or denies
those hypotheses anyway back to
psychoanalysis
i just i was never psychoanalyzed in the
lacanian strain but that's what i
understand about it
and i think that it it has a kind of
chaos magic element
that's not the right term but a sort of
like willful chaos introduced into it
because randomness is thought to just be
better
in the end because you're dealing with
randomness anyway so if you can deal
with it in a therapeutic frame
and the master is pivoting
to be the master that you need in that
moment then it should
theoretically help you to see the game
and then
be able to translate the game that
you've seen into the real world
and in a lakonian sense be able to deal
with the fundamental fact that fantasy
is always better than the reality so you
you better learn quickly as quickly as
possible to deal with reality as it is
and um enjoy your fantasies and pay the
price for having them
which is i don't know that is what it is
assuming my uh analysis there is even
remotely correct but that's
that's how i've i've come to understand
it what was it like to be a student of
slaveoyjack
it was um interesting so european
graduate school
operated in an interesting way so most
of the year is is offline and you do
your own reading
or sorry it's online and you do your own
reading and then you
you meet for six weeks every summer
and you have these seminars uh basically
every day for just
the hour equivalent that would be pretty
much close to a normal semester
so you spend a lot of time real fast
with these people
um and that's great because it's super
compressed
yeah but you don't have that much time
for um you don't have that much time for
uh what do they call it um you know
defragging your mind uh
percolating yeah it's uh it's it's it's
tough but it's it's fun
and you know the promise of european
graduate school is it lets you have
these professors that you're normally
not ever going to be able to have
like g jack and um you know when he was
alive i think darida taught there
uh lots of people i had peter greenaway
the filmmaker as a professor which
you know was the most amazing thing ever
uh
so it's really cool program i think
they're in malta now but at that time
they were in switzerland
when we talked about zero consciousness
and we're mentioning quantities of
consciousness that one
can't or either that's not useful or
it's not true to say that
some medicant monk has more
consciousness than us
then i was wondering well is there such
a concept of zero consciousness
what do you think of that do some
objects have zero consciousness
is zero consciousness a property of the
world
anywhere what would that look like
yeah i don't know uh i like i like a
thing in nietzsche it's a it's a small
little thing but
basically it says everything interprets
and
so what you could take that to mean is
that
everything that exists interprets the
forces of gravity
of entropy or whatever that's acting
upon it
right so it's not really literally
interpreting anything but
it has to deal with those forces but
whether it has consciousness or not
i don't know i mean this is where the
non-dualists who
who take physics and you know am i wave
am i a particle or all this stuff is
everything a wave function
i kind of get to your third question
which is so what
what changes if that proposition is true
what changes if it isn't
that's not the non-duality i'm talking
about i'm talking you know just
everything's a wave and so forth
yeah great if that's the case if you can
provide evidence for it which i don't
think
any of them really can i haven't seen i
mean i've seen that they provide
evidence but that evidence doesn't have
that
so what you know big bang it's not
compelling enough
have you heard of thomas campbell have
you read of
red thomas campbell's my big toe
i haven't no okay forget about that so
anyway you're saying that
what is the point you're getting to
point number three yeah
well if you take niches everything
interprets well i think that the point
is
quite nice you know that it's a zero-sum
game
you've got now maybe you're cursed to
repeat the same day
over and over and over again and you can
ask yourself if i'm cursed
to repeat the same day over and over
again knowing that i don't get to solve
the puzzle of whether
you know i'm an illusion or not knowing
that
the future is an image that appears in
you now what would that day look like
if you were cursed and then you can set
up the game so that
because you are cursed to live the same
day every day right because you're a
biological unit that has to eat
you have to go to the washroom you have
to suffer the oncoming
rush of age you have to suffer the fact
that you can't control others hell is
other people as sertra famously said
um so if you could design if you could
be an
artist that interacts with it what would
you do
and this is where i think the
non-duality i'm talking about is a
little bit more powerful
which is to say well hell all this stuff
is appearing
as far as i can tell it's appearing in
me and
i have all these pressures upon me but
these pressures have rules
the market has rules the internet has
rules and if i'm able to identify those
rules
and interact with them in such a way
that they enable me
to build a game so that i don't feel
hell every day
and every day is like much more
fulfilling than the day
you know and not knowing what's going to
come and i can just be in that day do
whatever i'm doing in that day some days
i'm not going to be as good as others i
might have a cold
my wife might be sick yada yada but i
still have this system that provides
pretty much that the curse of being
cursed
to live the same day every day is the
best possible day
given all the laws that govern reality
so that's the so what to me
and i think that those people are
creating a great contribution by
using their time on earth to create
ideas that stimulate thought and so
forth but i haven't seen the big so what
from them
and um maybe i'm not reading them close
enough
but they seem to be creating enemies
that aren't there
like materialism like where where are
the people in the street marching
saying you know oh well we've got to
treat
every object as not having consciousness
yes i know there are people who are
fighting for things that people don't
want like abortion and rights and etc
etc and that
are those are some of those implications
there but i don't see them having
any solution to that by saying well you
know
the scalpel too is conscious i mean so
what if it is
what changes if that's right nothing as
far as i can tell changes what changes
if it's wrong
well nothing as far as i can tell
because you're not going to be able to
stop people from writing those ideas or
sharing those ideas
so build a system in your life so that
you are as content as possible
to show up and if you can help people
along the way that's great and that is a
so what
because uh the evidence will be there
hmm
anthony to get a bit philosophical and
to play devil's advocate what would
happen if someone
said my ideal life is causing misery to
others
some peoples are yeah one may question
whether or not that's fulfilling and
then have a distinction between
momentary happiness and fulfillment or
purpose or whatever
let's let's not get that specific let's
imagine that they
are imbued with meaning when they
harm others and they say that this is my
life that i would put on repeat is me
harming others
so then what is the ethical action there
because it seems like they're fulfilling
that circle of
repetition of the day like groundhog day
it's a real problem my uncle was a
criminologist and he trained
police guards and they deal with that
question every day
there are people who not only
are content to be in prison but
they actually see prison as the place
where they even get to exercise
their ill intent even more right uh and
they
they just see the rules that govern that
reality and they use it
to exercise their evil intent inside of
that so
i don't necessarily have an observation
for or a answer to it
but it is in reality it does exist
and i think that if you're able to
somehow get
involved in studying that and figuring
it out you could contribute
to the betterment of the future for
those who are either blessed or cursed
depending on how they look at it to
to be in that future because there's
almost certainly
human brains and those brains are
governed by rules and some of those
people
uh it's not just sam harris you know
free will and
and and luck and fortune and chance it's
also
chance meeting biology uh or at least so
it
seems to me uh and so the amygdala for
example can be eroded in certain
individuals that causes them not only to
not care but to crave
you know violent acts against others and
we might be able to do something about
that
uh but we need people who are passionate
about that i happen to have an uncle who
was passionate about that and worked on
it and published on it and
trained guards to help them be better
guards in those situations and so on
and so forth and i think we can do a lot
about it but at the end of the day we
ought to look at it honestly
and we have to say this is biology
meeting chance and fate
and circumstance and now that they've
done this
you know what can we learn from it what
can we potentially do
this comes back to you know the
intelligence question um
can we can can we create
without creating more suffering because
it almost certainly is going to in the
beginning
can we create a world in which people
are on the same page
about ethical matters knowing that the
very meat
that processes ethical matters has
scarcity
it has all kinds of laws that drive it
to behave
to fulfill things in this moment without
much thought for the future that's what
it's designed to do
right can we do that and can we do it in
a way that you know
is going to work we don't know but we're
here so
obviously some people are going to try
and
i'd lean on let's do it let's put our
heads together and do it as right as
possible
but prepare to uh to fail
that i'm curious um let's
let's imagine that people are these
irrational robots
and i'm not sure that that is the
correct way of
understanding people but let's imagine
them in this computational
sense to be a black box it's not a
computer it's irrational
in a sense so we need to feed it
if we fed it what was rational what
would be outputted would be completely
irrational because that's the way
irrationality works
so then that means we need to feed it
something of
equal or opposite irrationality of what
we want
to be outputted is something positive
then
what i'm wondering is let's take an
atheist like sam harrison let's imagine
sam harris believes that we are
irrational beings
which it doesn't seem like that's too
much of a stretch would
what would you say
i know i'm speaking to sam harris in my
head but what would you say
anthony if someone said religion
now as for which religion like i'm
putting question marks on that
or if it's an existing religion putting
question marks maybe it's an amended
maybe it's a different kind that
religion is the
this irrational religion is this paper
that we feed into these irrational
beings called humans that allow them to
work with one another
is that okay or do you still see like no
no no we have to be guided by
what is absolutely true and what is true
is that there are no gods and there are
no god
i mean there is no god and so on and
christianity is false and buddhism is
false and so
so do we take this scientific view that
says
and to straw man science testimony
science would
that says that jesus is false and
buddhist buddhas falls and
all religions are simply myths
generated by irrational people to quell
themselves or because that was the best
they could do at the time
did we take that round and say we should
feed into these irrational beings the
truth
which is hey man you're deluded or
should we feed
them these irrational
quote-unquote stories of the bible or
the vedic text
and have them get together and cooperate
and produce something akin to peace
or something salutary
so what would you say where i would
start is look at what sam harris does
not what he says
right and what i mean by that i wish
that i would have saved it maybe i can
go back through my amas or whatever and
find it to correct my own memory if it
needs correcting
but i remember an ama for his supporters
back in the day
where people were asking him what were
the spiritual texts that you studied
and you know tell us some of them
and he said i don't want to tell you
what these spiritual texts are because
i'm concerned that people are going to
go
and uh you know wildly misinterpret them
this that
i see that danger because i've memorized
a lot of that stuff and it's a bit of a
mind twist to get around it and
get to uber atheism which is what i
think is in them right
but it's got a lot of spiritual verbiage
that can make you think there's a god
and that's
that's not really it's not that simple
and it isn't that that is not the
conclusion
but this is years ago and he says look
i'll give you one name
right and um and he mentions
i believe if my memory is correct he
mentions eduardo vedanta
and uh uh
i was so kind of i mean i love sam
harris
fan etc etc but i was a little bit
disgusted by this
because here's this guy who
has commands this massive audience and
he's going to police the knowledge
and say okay if you're going to study
this
here's like a little nugget for you but
i'm not going to tell you all the texts
that i studied when he's happy to tell
you like all the science texts
etc etc and he's got like massive book
recommendations
now skip forward a couple years the
waking up app appears
and now he's got adjacent as a guest
teacher who's just gonna
say all this stuff that he wasn't
willing to say and he put gates on
before
and i'm not judging him or anything i'm
just saying rather than what he says
that we should do
look at what he does right which is you
know
i don't know what it all is going to
culminate to but rather than having you
know
sam harris meditate with me live sort of
settings where you meet with him
at you know a mass convention and you're
all one together
and so forth he's got an app which is a
meditation app
that is built inside of a device that is
designed
to interrupt you right that's your
meditation app
and then it's filled with content that
directly contradicts
his years of suppressing
the spiritual texts that he didn't want
people to have that is now
wildly espousing them and i just
scratched my head a little bit about
this
because you know doesn't he have the
faith that
human people can figure it out for
themselves and so forth and
i mean i did i wanted to know i mean
what is it that you're reading it is
just like suppressed
suppressed suppressed and then he just
throws out this one nugget on one ama
and then years later all of a sudden
he's got andy shanti
and like other people in the spiritual
world
as if like what changed so what my point
is here is not to vilify
sam harris or anything like that but
rather just to say they're saying one
thing doing another
and um why that's the question why it's
because we all do
we all do so when you say should we do
this should we do that
i think we we're still not as humans
all together that there is a we that
could
do anything that we should do right and
i'm not sure that
the consequences of there being enough
of us on the same page
are going to be worth having but that's
what our technology is building
we're like if you look at like a douglas
hofstadter kind of
girdle escher buck looking things we're
ants
you know we don't we're communicating
something we're building something
do we know what it is that we're
building i don't think so but we are
building why because back to nietzsche
everything interprets
we are the scientists whether we are
whether we realize that we're doing
scientific experiments or not
humanity as such is collaborating to do
something
to an end that is an image in our
consciousness now
that can't possibly have convergence
across the board and can't ever possibly
become
what we might imagine that it would
become because we don't even agree on it
so
we got to step back and just think if
there's a we to do anything at all
and just think you know what can we do
now knowing that we are driven by forces
that are contrary to even the words that
come out of our mouths
to create that day that you know we
would be happily cursed to live in and i
think we are collaborating together
on things whether we whether we are
aware that we're collaborating
or or not everything we're saying right
now is being recorded because we
intentionally record it but you'd better
believe that it's being recorded whether
it be recorded or not
there's machines that are reading human
language as we speak
to try to figure out what humans are you
know
and what we should do is just not clear
to me at all because we
are doing something
we don't have to do anything that's
that's that is ultimately what
what the sam harris that's the
implications of what sam harris is
espousing
you couldn't do it if even if you tried
because you already have
forces acting upon you and if you're
lucky enough to have heard of the waking
up app
well good luck good fortune and
you know hopefully you will figure out
what those books are that he read
if you wanted to and you didn't have to
sort it's green and search forever
because you got a gatekeeper right
because the great promise of the
internet was to get rid of the damn
gatekeepers
but then what did it do it ultimately
ended up being populated with more
gatekeepers than we
ever could have you know imagined you
know so
what are we doing that's what i would
just ask not only
what is it that all this is going on but
who who exactly is it appearing to
who do you who is who are who is this
person you think you are
that it's appearing to and whether
whether sam harris is right that there
is no
i or that the i is just an illusion you
got to go one step further
which is that to whom is that appearing
to
right which is i don't know the answer
but i i i've worked it out for myself
and i keep working it out for myself
it's the most fascinating adventure it's
like it's like if you want to get out of
the matrix
that's the way is to ask the question
constantly
train your memory to constantly bring it
back to you
to whom is this even happening
do you believe in free will no but i
tend not to believe in anything why
would you believe in things
if it's true what do you need to believe
in it for
there's no evidence that there's free
will so i don't i don't see anything to
believe in and if it were true
i wouldn't need to believe in it
okay what does it mean to believe
well in that sense of the word belief
you know
it would be like and this is where
you know some lacanian psychoanalysis is
useful because some people
they create a kind of symbolic
big other right like mathematicians for
example
they um they will say no no math is not
invented math is
discovered right and so then when they
discover it
rather than seeing that yes it's both
discovered and invented i mean
assuming that's true i don't know but
i'm just sort of pointing out
a debate that's in the world but there
are a lot of people who
mathematically believe in or sorry they
believe in science
right they believe in it and they act
symbolically
as if it were a god right and
that's that's where they they are very
against themselves
so often because they're not looking at
the implications
of if they're go if that math was true
then why would they act that way
right they so they they believe in it
but they don't act as they
believe in it yeah i'm not following so
for example
when you say that this that science
becomes a god
and they act as if science is a god what
are you referring to
i'm not i'm not saying that they think
that science is a god or that they
act as if a science is god i'm saying
that there's a symbolic there's
there's a symbolic entity that is being
treated symbolically
as somehow a big a big other kind of
thing
right and they're not aware of that
symbolic relationship that they have to
it
uh i'm trying i'm gonna think about a
specific example with a friend of mine
um yeah sure so for example google is a
great god for him
and he uh we did some google ads one
time
and he said well if we just look at this
and we do recursion that and
mathematical formula this
if you spend this much on ads then this
should
exactly work right and uh i said okay
we'll run the experiment that's fine
and um he was like 100 sure of this
so we did all the symbolic behaviors
because the math told us
that this is what would happen right but
that's not what happened
it was just a it was just a a loss
and then i was having a discussion with
him and i said something's wrong with
your math right because the math here
showed that after a certain amount
compound this and
that that that then this would be in the
gr in the black
but we're we're deep in the red and he
defended the math like crazy
and he then you know started to started
to show me he said just
just let me show you and he got a piece
of paper and he wrote out the formulas
right now what i'm saying is instead of
just saying
you know what i don't know what's wrong
but it didn't work
he then started to symbolically
behave as if you could write out the
formula
and that would somehow cause me to
convert to believe that that math
was yeah what i understand okay okay
okay so when you say sorry
let me see if i'm understanding it
because if i say it but you see this a
bit in
you see that exact symbolic behavior all
the time
so i'm not saying that people believe in
math as if it's a god or anything
but they there's a symbolic behavior as
if there was this sort of okay thing
that it's eternally true
but eternity like if you look at like
julian barber i think his name is like
eternity he's just like what are you
talking about like
how is this even possible sorry i'm
interrupting you
go ahead he's this guy's a guest on the
podcast at some point soon
barbers okay well i think that
part of the issue with people like sam
harris and the and people who call
themselves atheists or even uber
atheists or whatever it may be
obviously i'm being a bit of a joker
myself with that yeah yeah is the issue
of what does it mean to be god
so i think they have let's take sam
harris and daniel dennett
as examples so the new atheists i think
that they have and please don't think
that i'm denigrating
atheism per se i'm not calling myself an
atheist or a theist
i would say that i don't know i don't i
i i'm
i'm i'm unsure
they have this idea that god yeah they
have this idea that god is
this old man in the sky that can that
tells you what to do and the people who
believe in god
are those who are will follow whatever
god says no matter what and are
staunched about
them being correct in their
interpretation of what god is however
there are people like
i'm not sure if this is aquinas or not
or if this even predates him but people
who say that
look the world god you mentioned that we
follow the math and the person was
saying that
well look the math says this it should
be so the world is wrong in a sense
in that example well i think it was
aquinas or someone who predates him that
said that
god is the way that we investigate the
bible let's imagine this is the bible
to some people this probably is the
bible let's imagine this is and we say
okay we think that this means that god
created the earth in seven days
however if we investigate the natural
world
god created the natural world in this
cosmology
and we find out that humans evolved from
chimpanzees from a common ancestry with
gymnasiums and so on and it was millions
and billions and so on
of yours well
the bible isn't wrong it's our
interpretation of the bible that's wrong
because the world
is the way the world is
and i don't see sam harris or daniel
dennett or any of the new atheists
tackling with that instead they
do what i think is a straw man argument
as to what
religion is and in a sense they take the
people from the new
borough baptist church i believe the
people who are
against homosexuals and so on and
and think that and creationists and so
on
they take them as representative of all
religion or of all that
god is meant to be but there are huge
interdictions
interdictions against stating exactly
what god is
now you might say one might say that's
like a huge cop-out because you want to
say that god exists but at the same time
you don't want to define what god is
but that's not that much of a cop-out
because
many people who are materialists we
don't think materialism is a cop out but
materials
would say that i don't know exactly what
is
because epistemically we can't know we
can only assume that there is something
independent of us and we interact with
it
okay well you're saying there is
something that exists but we have no
clue as to what it exactly is like
donald hoffman might say
donald hoffman's not a materialist but
you understand i don't
i don't see it as any more of a cop-out
so when people say yes this is what
religion is this is what god is and god
is not true or god doesn't exist
to me it's like well what are you
defining as god and why do you think
that that represents
what god actually is now i understand
the critique that someone
may have and it's the critique that
occurs to me or would have occurred to
me as
as a as an atheist a few years ago which
is that
it's just so vague and what is the use
of any of
of this well there is use i can get to
some of the use later
but either way the whole point is to say
when people are saying god doesn't exist
i don't know if they
are properly grappling with the issue
using the different definitions of god
which by the way there shouldn't be a
definition of god according to some of
the
scriptural accounts you shouldn't try to
define god in fact god is what
eludes definitions hmm-hmm there's much
i'd like to say but
i'm assuming that you understand where
i'm going with this
so what are your thoughts what occurs to
you when i say this
well i i would just kind of like point
us back to my
my claim that we should look at what sam
harris does not what he says right
because his behaviors are
somehow against themselves or against
itself
in terms of you know well we want to
restrict
people from having these woo-woo ideas
but you know my app is doing really
great so
why don't we get a bunch of people in
there who have all these woo ideas
and you know we'll get their audiences
too right
so what is he doing there now he's
acting symbolically towards the way the
market works
right so that i didn't quite get to that
point when i was going through the what
he does rather than
what he says thing right because new
atheism
evolved as it did the way many things do
because the market was responding to it
right
and then it it peaked and then it
started to fizzle out and now a new
thing comes
right so i hope spirituality wave
yeah yeah i hope i'm not copping out by
just going in this
direction but i think that this is the
answer
what is the behavior that's going on and
how
is that either literally i often use
this word
symbolic behavior but like how how is
that behave what is that behavior saying
about the thing that says there is a god
in the first place i mean are cows going
around talking about god
or uh fish talking about god no it's
humans that are talking about god right
so part of the answer to this and
spinoza i think is a great person to
study on this
you know who's talking about god well
spinoza is and he's aware of this right
and so he then starts to think about
well ethical behavior and
this that and could you live forever and
he comes up with these solutions to
you know that and he says well basically
you are going to live forever at some
level because
as long as there are humans which are
information storage and retrieval
devices
then part of the information that passed
through you is also going to pass
through them
so stop worrying about it you know your
your um
your your your eternal nature is already
secured so long as there are humans
through which information can be stored
and retrieved and
i think that that's the answer in many
many ways or i feel that that's the
answer
to the question of does god exist or not
who's talking about it
how are they talking about it and in
what ways
is there congruence between what they're
saying and what they're doing
right because there's a lack of
congruence
all across the board including in myself
and that's what you would predict from
humans
so you know take it or leave it but
that's that's my answer to the god
question who's having it
how are they behaving and where's the
congruence in what they're saying and
what they're doing
speaking on free will i heard you say
that there's no evidence for free will
but well there's no evidence for your
existence either there's no evidence
that you're conscious
there's no evidence that i don't think
is the case
let's say let's talk about free will and
i don't understand why people
are so adamant about that free will
exists or that it doesn't exist
i mean i understand it to some degree
because people eve like even daniel
dennett
would say that free will hinges on
responsibility or responsibility
depends on free will and so on but
regardless of that there are
extremely extremely bright
neuroscientists for example
the world's most preeminent
neuroscientist his name is carl firsten
he has the most citations he has an h
index of over 200. over 200 as an h
index
brilliant brilliant scientists don't
have over a hundred like it's hard to
get over 50
of it on an h index he has over 200.
anyway even he is like well
and he's a neuroscientist even he says
there is
free will may exist and he has a model
for free will nicholas justin who's a
quantum physicist without without
appealing to the quantum nature of
consciousness like some people do
he says you can't disprove free will in
the same way that you can't disprove
that
real numbers or integers are properties
of
matter that i know that sounds a bit
technical but there is an association
there
either way i don't know how people can
take one side of that issue
it's so contentious and it's not as if
there's evid there's
overwhelming evidence one way or the
other so either way whatever i want to
hear what do you think about that
well i think i think it's easy to
evidence why there's no free will as
such but
we've got to define our terms right
because there's difference between acts
of oil
and free will as it's often discussed
which is
you know nuanced what what exactly is
meant there
but notice something here and this is
this is an answer to the free will
question
you wanted to make sure and please don't
be offended if i use you as an example
yeah i do this i do this myself all the
time too
200 citations 200 citations right now
why
would a human go out of their way to
couch a presentation of something in
that well that's because we
symbolically i would use that word we
symbolically
imbue value on things by our training
so when we talk about free will i would
say that that is part of the evidence of
the absence of free will
because that is something you've seen
other people do that is something i've
seen other people do it's something i've
done myself this is the guy right
because he's got 200
publications so that behavior is already
starting to show
that humans don't have free will because
humans are playing
out theatrical and
you know grammatical and
rhetorical patterns in the same way a
jazz musician trains themselves
not not to like invent in the moment but
they just have this code
of licks that they are just super tiled
into and they know what key they're in
and they just rip
right because that's what we're doing
we're jamming right now we're jazzing
and riffing
but the idea that we're doing it of our
own free volition is just patently false
we're using a language that we didn't
invent that was drilled into us because
we were exposed to it we didn't have any
choice
in i was born in british columbia you
know
wherever individuals were born i don't
know you know i just was there that's
the language i got
and so that's the one that i encoded
that's the one i riff with
whatever comes out comes out based on a
certain fitness
with with that language but i didn't
choose any of it right
i didn't choose for youtube to you know
some time ago
show me your channel the richard hire
things come come up i didn't choose to
be interested in memory
it just was thrust upon me it's not
exactly
um heideggerian geworfenheit or you know
being thrown
into the world but in some sense that's
what we are
so yes there are all kinds of little
ways to talk about acts of will
and how that we have agency to act in
the world
but overall and i think this is where
i think a lot of people miss and i don't
even think that sam harris is
necessarily doing that good of a job on
it
but there's the finesse here what we're
talking about is essentially
being thrown into the world and not
having much to say about it
i can walk out some more this morning
it's morning here in australia i can go
to the cafe and get hit by a bus
right i don't i don't have nearly as
much i might be as cautious as
i want to be i can look left i can look
right
and a rock can still fall from the sky
so you know
so much is contingent upon chance that
the notion of
of me having much choice in in what i
ate
three days ago in a 72-hour cycle not
causing me to go ballistic
and uh do some crazy stuff and i have a
mental illness right
i i mean it's just where's the free will
in any of this
i'm i'm a biological unit who has
somehow become aware of being a
biological unit
and i i'm i'm strapped to the meat tube
here's what occurs to me when i hear
that what you've demonstrated is only
constraints or influence so for example
the books on the shelf behind you though
they're fake because it's an image it
doesn't matter whatever screen
right exactly okay so imagine one of
those books fell and you say well it
didn't have the free will to fall
because first of all it didn't choose
itself to be a book
second of all it wasn't it didn't choose
which shelf it was on okay but all of
that just demonstrates that there are
constraints placed
not that there's a complete lack of free
will and as for
the the heavy heavy heavy heavy 99.99 no
99.99
percent influence of the world over your
own actions that's true
now there could be zero point zero zero
zero zero zero zero with
and with the 35 zeros and then a one
even if you choose that little one
somehow choose it's not clear what
choose means because
we get into notions of causation how do
you cause once how does one
self cause oneself how does one cause
oneself
one's action that's not easy but
not to get into quantum physics or to
pretend that quantum physics is the
answer
i'm only using quantum physics as an
analogy to
to demonstrate that it's possible that
they're
that they're you can think of a particle
now this is maybe personifying a bit too
much but you can think of a particle
let's say one that decays
okay let's say how do you know when it's
going to decay does it choose when to
we don't know the answer to that we
don't imbue uranium with a personality
but but you you can think of it in a
sense of free will there's someone named
nicholas jessen he says that science
presupposes free will
as well so if you're going to invalidate
free will based on a scientific
framework you can't because you
presuppose free will
in the formulation of science how
because you have to stand outside and
freely choose your experiment as a
scientist
in order to uncorrelate yourself from
the
data otherwise all your data is
completely corrupted if
if i know that every time look there's a
red light behind me if
if all if my looking there causes the
red light or looking at the screen
causes the red light
i can't say that that red light exists
so there has to be some independent
quality of myself
and my and the data so that's another
reason why i don't know if one can use
science to invalidate free will when
it presupposes it to begin with and
and you mentioned these constraints and
that's 100 correct there are constraints
by the way i'm not arguing free will
exists just so you know i'm just saying
that
i don't i i don't unders i i see some
that there
to be per to be frank when i hear some
people adamantly say that free will
exists or if free will doesn't exist
i have the sneaking suspicion that they
have some other psychological motivation
to say so
or that they have already come to that
conclusion and now they're justifying it
the reason i say that is because it's
such a difficult issue why would you be
so
why would you take one side or the other
like
the more you study it the more you
realize there's absolute conflict and
people like sam harris
have podcasts about no there's
uniformity in the neuroscientific
community about
free will not no there absolutely isn't
even people like like i mentioned call
carl firsten and
and anil seth and you also mentioned
well kurt you're
you're being you're being
wide-eyed and bushy-tailed about collegi
collegiate approval and like with the
citations and so on
that is true in a sense although we do
when evaluating the scientific
experiments that invalidate supposedly
invalidate free will
we also do that so in the invalidation
of free will
there is still the use of this tool
that you say
i've lost my train of thought hopefully
you can
pick up the cards that i've just thrown
on the floor yeah well
look i i'm all up for it too and i love
to read
these things and you know go through the
ideas and
so forth i haven't i haven't really
decided i've just said i don't see
compelling evidence that there's free
will
but i'm open to all kinds of evidence
but in the free will
as i mean it i still don't see evidence
of it rather i see the opposite
because part of the free will is could
you go back and change what you did
right
and that's not possible because the past
is an image
inside of you and or you know it's it's
a memory inside of you and you can go
back and change memories that's for sure
but your very memory
is already corrupt so you talked about
data corruption you know like standing
outside of it and
that would correct your data hold on
data is
always already stored somehow it's all
maybe not always but it's
you know not exactly as pure as one
would make it and so forth and then in
our own memories
we don't even know that we remembered
what we remembered as accurately as we
could right
so in that sort of thing of like hey
look at how science you know we we use
this language 200
sort of stuff uh 200 publications and
that means yeah it was
but that's um
to me that again comes back to the core
sort of
thing i wish we would focus more on as
humans which is
if if they are if if the scholarly sort
of approach
uh is going to have any kind of weight
to it then
there is this notion that we have to
accept that truth is not only somewhat
contingent upon change because
new data changes it but we also have to
accept that there are tribal
battles and that humans behave in
symbolic ways in order to win those
tribal battles
so what harris is doing when he says oh
there's absolute convergence on this
topic in the neuroscientific community
that's of symbolic behavior that is a
battle cry that is
that is propaganda that is no different
than the ancient
uh hebrews writing a letter to the
warring tribe which later gets codified
in the bible
it can be in the future that you know
somebody's going to write a book about
neuroscience and they're going to cite
sam harris's
episode and maybe even have the whole
transcript and it's going to be you know
part of
a larger text that is in the battle
against so and so
so my big call towards this is
essentially nichian in nature which is
we are driven
to behave in certain ways according to
biological imperatives
and whether we call it free will this
free will that we define it that way
at the end of the day are we aware of
those biological imperatives
and are we aware when we are structuring
hierarchies
referring to hierarchies perhaps cow
towing a little bit to this hierarchy a
little bit less than that
are we aware of this and are we aware of
the implications of it
and when we're preaching stuff are we
practicing it are we even capable of
practicing it
why do you think jordan peterson is so
popular right now because he's obviously
the guy who cannot practice what he's
preaching
but he's damn close in some sense right
and he's just constantly you know
uh pointing us to the impossibility of
the very thing that we should strive for
knowing that so many chips are stacked
against us
now whether he's right or wrong i'm not
saying i'm just saying look at the
popularity of it
why would that go so you know people say
well it's because you need we need a
father figure yeah
yeah etc well why would we need one well
it's because we don't have enough will
in ourselves to you know have a have a
compass
to have something to pattern ourselves
after because without
adopting a frame of reference without
having something to copy even if it's a
bad copy
then you know our free will does nothing
for us
having free will is nothing without a
referent
so again it's just kind of like a so
what
i'm all for people battling and this and
that and evidence this and that
it all just still comes down to if
you're right what changes
and so far i haven't seen a whole lot
changing and i don't know that it ever
will
except for maybe elon musk succeeds with
neurolink and um
that we can all download enlightenment
but are we going to want the
consequences
of what enlightenment is and i don't
think so
you know you don't want it forced on you
i don't think so
what would the consequence of
enlightenment be
you'd realize this is a zero-sum game
this is it so you're gonna you know buck
up or shut up because now's the time to
enjoy
and they're coming back so you know be
awake
just as it is
that's that's what enlightenment is what
else would it be
meaning
say that in another way please
so for whatever reason that nobody seems
to know
they like to have a lot of opinions
about it they like to say that there's
evidence for it
we're here right now yes
we're having this discussion right now
yeah supposedly
at least i think we are yeah whatever
that's the point what changes if we
aren't what if this is all
illusion what changes nothing there's
still death there's still taxes
it's still like you know this this meat
tube is going to show up
and die in a hospital one day or die at
home it's going to
pay the bills et cetera like nothing
changes whether this is real or not
as far as i can tell you aha okay so
this is interesting
i see what you're saying mm-hmm okay i
would say
i can pay my taxes with bliss i would
see okay now this is a
this is an extremely technical argument
and i can't even recapitulate it it's
it's it's absolutely
well it's it's riveting if it's but it's
it's tricky there's something called the
free energy principle i don't know if
you've heard it's called carl first and
i keep mentioning him because
i spoke to him earlier today and
carl fristen says that what we are what
anything
now thing can give you can give a
technical definition as to what a thing
is
what anything is is
that survives you can give a technical
definition as to what it means to
survive
is something that is self-organizing so
now we get
into ideas that are similar to life so
self-organizing
and that has beliefs about what's
outside of it and then can act on those
beliefs and also take some sensory
information
now what's interesting is in his model
which by the way
if it's to be believed then it's
extremely extremely general
it's an extremely general argument which
works even if the laws of physics were
slightly different it works in an
extremely abstract sense as to as to
what is a thing
and this is why saying this with words
is
difficult because it requires a precise
mathematical formulation and even that
is
it's not simple math it's
first second year math but the
but it's still not simple it's not
simple math okay
he said that let's imagine this little
guy here this is a cell
now the cell could be a person as well
it could be a society even whatever
it could be it can be a single cell it
has beliefs about the outside
then what's interesting is if it
has a different belief it actually
changes the world so when you say well
what's the difference if so and so is
the case or is not
well what what changes is sure
the world at that instant doesn't change
but the world will then change later
your beliefs influence your action and
it
there's an inextricable link between
them so that's what i would say and
actually in some way you co-create the
universe
so the universe outside you this is
strange because
well it's not strange it's it's it's
technical in the sense that
i i'm let's imagine that i'm inside here
and i'm in a home
right now and there's walls now if this
was a living being
then somehow i have to be sensing the
outside world and then it have to be
acting so these walls have to be moving
and
messing around with the world but what's
interesting is in that formalism
the world you can there's a duality
between the inside and the outside
and that means you can also view the
world as acting on me
in the in an equivalent manner which
means that my beliefs actually
change the world so when someone says
well what difference does it make
if this belief was to be believed or or
not
well in carl fr and i would 100 be that
down
down that route a month or two months
ago but
mathematically actually your own beliefs
do change
the world even right they changed the
world they changed the world that's
right they're reflecting what do we mean
by the world though what is the world
what does that even mean
right okay so here's how it's defined
here's how it's defined let's
imagine there are let's imagine we have
a checkerboard and they're just dots on
the checkerboard
and then let's imagine that you can
connect some of the dots
any amount of the dots in any which way
okay so now this looks like a
complicated
um game of checkers with lines in
between them
like a serial killer has lines sorry
like the detective has lines trying to
find the
the serial killer with with newspapers
on the walls and
connection between them and then let's
imagine you put arrows and that means
this influences this this influences
this
okay that's all that's meant by the
world is that there exists
there exists nodes and some can
influence one another as to what those
are those could be a society influencing
a person
it could be a person influencing society
could be a cell influencing a rock it
could be a rock
it's it's left absolutely general so
that's what's meant by the world in this
okay well to be charitable to that then
we have to say we have to go back to
intelligence right
so the people who have the most
intelligence are doing a real bad job
because if they can change the world
you know just by thinking a certain way
then
they are either quite weak right now or
they're incredibly strong but they're
the battle that they're fighting is is
stronger right
so it just comes back to if it's true
what changes and if it's not true what
changes but if that kind of thing is
true that thoughts can change the world
and so forth
then we we appear to be in a frame a
game that has an 80 20 distribution
and the 20 of the people who are so
gifted to even sit there and concentrate
on changing the world in a positive way
they're not doing very good you know or
they're doing
all too well you know against the forces
that they battle with
but i think it's a little bit of a
stretch to think that
you know that is what's happening and i
would personally feel
that with the amount of intelligence
that i have whatever you would call that
i don't know how you
would would uh sum it up i'm a failure
because
damn if i can change the world just by
changing my you know my thoughts
i'm not doing nearly enough you know and
i can't
i i i can't see that i've accomplished
nearly as much as i should be able to if
that's true
or or i can just pat myself on the back
and say man
there are masters out there who are
better than you maybe one day kid maybe
one day i see what you're saying
i think that it's just those kinds of
things just circle us back to
the same position okay let me see if i
understand what you're saying
so taking this idea of
one's own thoughts can change the world
and then
stretching that out and saying if i can
change the world why can't through a
sheer
force of will or through a sheer shift
of beliefs
why can't i drastically improve the
conditions of many people on the earth
is it something like that spider-man 101
with great power comes great
responsibility so buck up cowboy if you
can do that
let's go like let's see it and the fact
the better is there are people who are
doing incredible things
but are they doing it are they doing it
because the proposition that you have
laid out
i'm not saying that you you yeah yeah
yeah you're forwarding it but yeah
is it is the impact that they're
creating on the world is it because
that that proposition is true or is it
that they're creating
impact in the world because of something
else that governs
the other laws that govern reality
like really i mean because if we can
figure that out
then maybe maybe some true
uh you know what they sometimes called
the omega point will happen
or you know the singularity will happen
is that from janus i mean this that from
julian barber the omega point or is that
from someone else
uh well it's uh i think it's from the
19th century a french jesuit
priest um but he may have mentioned i
haven't read that book yet but um
uh he may mention it he may well i think
dennett mentioned it too the omega poi
someone mentioned they'll make a point
and i'm just trying to recall who it was
i know that they weren't the originators
of it but
but the omega point has a negative
consequence too because part of that
idea
uh was then taught i think it was
jacqueline in the technological society
which came out in the 70s at some point
he had said yeah if that sort of thing
happens then imagine humanity builds a
machine and then that machine
figures out how to reproduce its own
matter
it would then most likely fill all
available matter with itself
pushing out everything else um but that
might be what's happening already anyway
i don't know um but that's not that's
certainly not for
you know the betterment of anything
necessarily
just just being its selfness uh
totally but maybe that's what the
universe already is and it's selfness
trying to be itself totally um but i
again those those ideas are fun there i
think there's a genre of people so to
speak
who just love playing around with those
kind of ideas but it always comes back
to
so what uh what can we do with that now
and
it's possible like i go back to the ant
behavior metaphor
we've got all kinds of helper ants on
the planet we've got some ants that are
like super ants maybe and maybe
all of humanity maybe is conspiring to
help elon musk create neural link
so that it actually works so that we
don't have to send humans to mars
we can just send chips into space that
decode our consciousness
maybe that's what humans are doing but
if they're doing it
based on the proposition that you said i
mean
you can read it either way damn there's
some powerful
thought ninjas out there or have what
took so long you know
i don't know but at the end of the day i
don't find it a satisfying proposition
at all um myself but that's okay that's
okay let's get to germany let's get to
some german language
when we first exchanged some emails i
asked you
there there's a professor who speaks
there's actually two
who speak german and who give wonderful
wonderful wonderful physics lectures and
i don't know how to speak
german so i i watch their english
lectures but it's not but i would love
to see the german ones as well and i
thought well
how can i learn german and then i
as at that point i was already
exchanging emails with you and i saw
that
you're somewhat of a language expert
yourself so i thought well
why don't i ask anthony as to how can
one go about learning german
efficiently given this is my goal i
don't need to be conversational
and go to germany i don't care about
that i care about understanding
these lectures now i can clearly just go
to the
youtube translation and put in the
closed captions for english
and i have done that but it's boring
because
i have to read and then i have to watch
i want to see his facial expression is
he joking when he says so and so
and the translations aren't perfect and
it is distracting to read and to try and
listen at the same time and i thought
man it would be wonderful if i could
speak german but then um
and then you told me well here's how you
can do it but then i thought
man that requires so much more work than
at least but you can tell me if i'm
wrong but this is what it occurred to me
i'm like man
this is way harder than i thought and i
thought it would be as simple as
so you can spend two weeks part-time
curt like at the end of a night just an
hour a day for two weeks
that is 14 hours in total and and learn
german to the degree that you
want to learn it i don't think that's
true and i thought that that i was
hoping that would be the case
anyway i think do you think
for my goals forget about
learning german in general for my goals
now that you know what
specifically what they are do you think
that it's it's better for me to
learn the german that he speaks in
that lecture or should i just
swallow the pill of finding it difficult
to
to read the closed captions at the same
time and just read them
and go through it which one do you think
is a better use for my time given that
my goal is simply
to understand those lectures in german
i think well first i have to say i don't
know
but i would advise you to learn german
as such because
at some level that guy is speaking
german as such
and then if you think of german as
having many aspects to it
there's there's the the hawk deutsche
that he's speaking or
german as such let's call it and then
there's going to be the technical
language which i noticed a lot of those
titles are uh
you know essentially the the german
version of
terms we would recognize in english
anyway right yeah yeah
but then there's yeah there's going to
be
there's going to be a lot of nuance that
comes from
the way german is used in those
technical fields so you
then want to spend some time figuring
out you know how is he using german how
do scholars use german
because scholastic german is is quite
nuanced um
that's a different type of german what a
language is is
already complicated and if we're using
german as an example
i mean there is a thing called hak
deutsch which is sort of the codified
german
that they want you to speak you know to
unify the country
and whether or not people actually speak
it or not
that is the question because i learned
german in both
east germany or in berlin and uh often
lived in the east part of berlin
and i learned it in west germany uh in
saarbrucken
near the french border which is quite
influenced by french
uh in in pronunciation and yadda yadda
so there's many germans to learn
so i would i would figure out what what
city that guy lives in
and you know try to um or those guys
live in
and try to figure out you know can you
find examples to work from
that may be helpful with their accent
and so forth
but definitely learn german as such
because every technical german that
they're
learning or they're using
so i'm not i'm not sure that there is a
an actual term
for for like this and shaft deutsch
which would be scientific german but
there is
going to be in that genre in that in
that foch
which is subject fock deutsch i guess
you would maybe call it i don't know i'm
just
you can do this with german like you
could just make stuff up yeah
so it must be that somebody has used
that term before but it would be like
subject german
um so you're going to have like these
onion layers and the more you learn
you know the more you appear into it but
there's like he might be from a region
that speaks plat deutsch
or you know he might be uh berlinerish
or something like this
like i don't know uh he could be highly
inflected by certain things his students
would know
because they know german as such and
they you know you would be able to guess
but man i've been in cities where on one
street they say
ish kaufa and one block over they say
ichacuff which is the same thing
yeah i recall you saying that and for
the people listening
anthony was so kind to me so kind that
when i just exchanged three emails
in total with him three by the third
email i said hey this is by the way what
i'm thinking about
learning he recorded a 15 minute lecture
for me essentially
on his computer 15 minutes of his own
time it wasn't quick
it wasn't fast typing keyboard letters
it was
actual 15 minute screen recording him
speaking to me speaking to the camera
for me to listen to later
i found that to be so i didn't thank you
enough for that so thank you please
i didn't i'm sorry if i i'm curt to
use a pun i'm kurt over emails well this
is this is my karma yoga this is how i
do the nietzschean proposition i'm
cursed to live every day
so why not live it in the way that makes
me feel blissful
well i i'm i'm honored and i don't think
i'm grateful enough
for the fact that you find bliss in
helping me or helping others in general
but at least for me i'm the only one
that can feel this right now so
i don't think i'm grateful enough and
thank you for oh my pleasure i think it
was the buddha who said that expectation
is the
quickest path to suffering so had i
expected anything from you that would
have been my failure but i'm glad that
yeah i'm glad that it uh it helped you
or it impacted you or
impressed you or whatever it did um but
that's the secret
that's the secret of how to memorize uh
german
or to learn german using memory
techniques okay i'm gonna get to now
some audience questions okay all right
i don't know if you have this issue but
when i ask people for audience questions
i i find it so difficult to read their
questions
i don't know why if it's text from a
book it's different but if it's
audience questions i don't know if
if they're not realizing that i'm that
it's
easier for me to read it verbatim and
that sometimes it doesn't make sense the
way that they've written it
or if i'm just processing it differently
because it's an audience question but i
have such a difficult time
with reading audience questions i can
read quotations completely fine from a
book but audience questions i have a
difficult time so sorry
martin if i'm not reading your entire
question i'm going to read this has
improving your memory led you to
believing there is no free will
well it has changed how i experience
reality that's for sure but back to what
we talked about before i don't
believe things or i try to avoid the
idea of believing things because why
would i need to believe something that
was true
so it is true that memory has changed
how i experience
my acts of will in the world and why
because
i have worked a lot on a particular
procedural
training which is when my little mind
goes oh this sucks or this is a waste of
time
or i hate this damn thing i just have
trained myself
is this thought useful and you know that
has changed everything
because i didn't choose to have those
thoughts i don't have will in it
you know i'm working on annihilating it
totally if that's possible i don't know
gary weber says it's possible a lot
thousands of you know people
say in their books that it's possible
that you could have complete lasting
nirvana here on earth or whatever nervy
kalpa samadhi i think they call it
um so i'm just working on it just to see
if it's possible but i've let go of the
outcome
please give the cliff notes version of
the ted talk for the audience because
you mentioned this a couple times
of not finding your thoughts useful or
asking that question and yeah
and how useful that has been so do you
mind giving that
giving giving a quick recap yeah well
the long and short of it is i have
dealt with mental health issues for a
very long time
and some of them involve what is
typically called harm ocd
and a lot of it is just really nasty
and uh i've just suffered with thoughts
and self-denigration blah blah blah like
you name it
uh and it happens still to this day i
used to take medication for it
and then i stopped i was doing like a
biohacking experiment and started using
bulletproof coffee instead of
psychiatry what year was that uh that i
stopped psychiatric medicine or whatever
you tried bulletproof coffee
oh that would have been 2015. oh it was
fairly recent huh yeah i stopped
medication in 2015 and just started
doing my own thing to
deal with mental health issues and
it was risky i did it with doctor
supervision this is not
advice to anybody but you know i did it
what i think is the right way with
doctor supervision and uh
also i had a health coach and yeti but
anyway
just to get back to what the talk is
about i started to i had always
meditated but it hadn't really
created you know these masterful
experiences except for
i had these weird experiences of like a
bit of light in the
center of my forehead sometimes and uh i
came to brisbane and i met a guy
long story but we know each other from
the internet and we were talking about
atheism and we were talking about
spirituality and he's a
he has a website called project monkey
mind and he works a lot
on helping people with psychiatric
issues and etc
and bringing more mindfulness through
journaling anyway we're talking about
this stuff
and i said you know i'm not gonna
he said have you ever tried chanting or
any of that because you can memorize
stuff
and i said i'm never going to do that
because i just the religious people
they're the enemy like i was really at
that time
before uber atheism this is before uber
80's yeah obviously i was
i was hook line and sinker with the new
atheists kind of stuff you know
us versus them kind of crap and um
i'm sympathetic to them still but that's
what the way it was and he just said
he said to me have you ever heard of
gary webber and i was like no who the
hell's that
and he said well he used to be like you
he he he actually
wanted to find a meditation program to
stop his own mental thoughts
the suffering he had extreme suffering
and somehow he came across the idea of
the sanskrit
he memorized all the sanskrit and one
day his thoughts went away and i'm
like what do you mean his thoughts went
away he's like just gone and i just said
bs right but i pride myself a little bit
in being a skeptic
like a true skeptic which i go out and
investigate so i read
gary weber's books and then i thought
huh well i i i know memory techniques i
can memorize all of this sanskrit i can
do it
correctly or quickly and let's see what
happens
and lo and behold would you know it
i i started to feel way better
and i started to have this tool and i
started to be tortured less and less and
less by these thoughts my wife noticed
it all my friends noticed it
my youtube audience noticed it i was
just freer
happier etc and then one day i got
really mad at the internet and it was
partly related to that google ad
experiment that i was telling you about
yeah yeah
nick i almost threw my laptop out the
window and i just
said no no i go for a walk anyway i go
and i sit in the park and all of a
sudden my thoughts did disappear and i
mean gone
and i was just like what the hell is
this and that
touched me so deeply and it's it's like
a
tuning fork was hit that still is
ringing to this day
and i still have thoughts but man it's
been it's just
it's paid off i worry about sound like a
religious nut but
it was um i think it's scientifically
explainable
and as weber explains it this is the
default mode network that is like i
i me me this is the task positive
network which is more in the moment flow
not too concerned about the future not
too concerned about the past etc
more more aware of the present moment
and it makes total sense so i just have
kept practicing
and i i pretty sure that if you tested
it with other people it doesn't have to
be sanskrit
but i think there is something to the
knowledge because the knowledge
in the sanskrit that i've memorized is
just trying to remember you to get you
to remember
this is it this moment is it so use it
wisely
you know and that thought that you're
having it's like a little child it's a
little boy that's
like not behaving so you know
get rid of it the idea that you are real
it says in the sanskrit
is as rare as a rabbit with horns which
makes you laugh when you
when you remind yourself of the sanskrit
but why has it come to mind
because of procedural memory training
and that's why i think
and and if you read gary weber between
the lines that's what he's saying he
still has planning thoughts
he still has to you know do whatever
people have to do as long as they're a
meat tube that are walking the planet
you know
he's not tortured just not tortured and
i'm not tortured anymore and it's so
amazing
this was around 2015 well this project
breaking memory started in
the breakthrough started in 2017. but i
that's interesting i had some help from
getting off the medicine and i also quit
drinking because i was a
i was a lush i mean i lived in germany
how about psychedelics or even
weed marijuana
yeah i i i spent a lot of time with
those things
unfortunately i started with it too
young i when i was 14 i had a really bad
experience
which was really good in its way as well
i think it was
i think it had the impact that that a
lot of people talk about i've never done
ayahuasca but like i think it
had a similar impact basically what
happened is i dropped double
a double dose at lunch hour in grade
nine okay
and uh double dip blue moon it was
called that's and i was
yeah i was fine i had to leave school
because it was getting too intense quite
quickly
but uh by about 9 p.m i i thought i had
peaked and was done
and i went and saw some friends and they
were smoking something to this day i
don't know what it is
but uh it was it was laced maybe with
pcp
but i just took the can and i huffed
like you wouldn't believe
and let me tell you on top of the double
dip yeah that acid was not over i mean
my friends later told me or i heard
somewhere that there's a thing a
phenomenon called roller coaster acid
which is you can feel like you're peaked
and back to normal but you haven't
peaked yet
so anyway somewhere that night i peaked
but man i i
i lived an eternity that night and uh
let's just say i was lucky that i had
some people who helped me read
carlos castaneda for example um
who also had some pretty intense drug
experiences that helped me contextualize
it a little bit
and from there i got into you know
hermann hesse and
camus and stuff so i had tools to help
me but i was destroyed i had anxiety
for uh i was around age 14 i had really
bad anxiety until i was about 37 or so
um that's that's that's so strange
because
well i guess if you're 14 that's
completely different for people who are
adults psychedelics are salubrious they
actually help
oh believe me i before that experience i
had lots of
fun experiences with lsd but we used to
live beside a guy who was a ubc chem
major
and he would bring home lots that he had
created in the lab and he'd say
have a try of this and tell me why he's
pure well yeah
that's what he said but yeah um
we would name it for him oh yeah let's
call this electric dragon and uh yadda
yadda
and that guy you know true he's good
he's like he's not in jail but i never
i never told until uh until now i mean
i've told a few people over the years
but
i don't remember his name or who he was
but what a [ __ ] given that to teenagers
as an aside speaking of of unscrupulous
people in the
educational field there was this teacher
that i had maybe i'll tell the story
another time but i'll give you
a quick version of it there's this
teacher i had who this was back when you
could burn cds
and video games and so on and now you
can just download them right okay so
this is
2004 or so and
he would i hated the class that i was in
i hated it was plenty of memorization
that i didn't care about
maybe if i had taken your lessons i
i would i would have found it to be a
fun exercise but i saw it as a
it's an imposition anyway he said okay
well why don't you first why don't you
burn me some games and i'll give you
grades
so first of all burning burning cds at
all is
illegal and then second he's like i'll
just give you good grades for it
anyway okay well i'm fortunate to have
him
that's teachers are humans too right
yeah yeah
okay okay let's get to another question
sure sure yeah okay someone wants to
know who are your favorite authors to
read in german now that brings me back
to that gary
weber i don't know if he's german or not
but what one book if people
from this were to take away just one
book of his which one would you say is
the most helpful
oh i i don't think it's one but
happiness beyond thought and evolving
beyond thought those two kind of they
kind of go together
but if you had to pick one just roll the
dice i mean i don't know
yeah each one is fine and which order if
you could pick both
which one would you read first well in
my experience
and this is what gary weber points out
in happiness beyond thought don't try to
reproduce the journey of somebody else
it's not going to happen so
it's like irrelevant which order you
read them or i i can't predict but i
read happiness beyond thought first
i started getting some great results out
of it but it was really a memorizing the
script
in evolving beyond thought where the
game started to change
and that script is select selections
from the ribhugita
and i mean if you want to talk about
uber atheism there it is i mean it's
it's the implications of that sort of
prove the proposition of uber atheism
that i'm
saying i have just i personally have
arrived at
from looking into sanskrit after that i
went back and memorized the sanskrit
in um happiness beyond thought which is
from a text called the
uh upadesa sharam uh and uh there's some
extracts there from
bhagavad-gita uh in any case
look just uh if you will if you're
interested in that kind of stuff give it
a try
keep an open mind but not so open that
your mind you know falls out and um
i found it incredibly useful i think
i've got good reasons why that
why that it's useful but the point is
don't try to reproduce the teacher and
have a have a goal i had a goal i wanted
to stop this
nonsense chatter or at least reduce its
negative impact in my life and it's
worked so well
but i also did the dietary stuff i got
rid of alcohol
i haven't had alcohol or drugs for many
years now and i feel like almost every
year i get cleaner and cleaner because i
drink a lot
um so i wouldn't pin it all on
memorizing some sanskrit even though it
i see it i see it the knowledge of it
has been huge
for dealing with thoughts because it
says in the atma boda
uh constant practice uh neutralizes
ignorance as a base neutralizes an acid
purifying the individual self
so basically practicing what knowledge
well the knowledge that now is the only
moment what other knowledge could be
more impactful
i don't know but uh constantly
practicing it is really great
in terms of german authors or german
books
i mean patrick suskind i was very lucky
to read german well enough that i
eventually got to read
that kurt cobain suggestion from when i
was a teenager in german
absolutely amazing book um there's a
book called
dating berlin that i really like which
is written by an ex-prostitute
who had immigrated to berlin from italy
and uh i really like that book a lot uh
i don't know if we can swear on your
channel but it's part two of another
book that has a
has an english swear word in it and so i
will allow people to search that
i personally don't care about the
swearing it's more about
foolish worry of the demonetization you
know i even wanted to
i even wanted to look up or inquire into
kovit in the vaccine because from what
i'm here i'm hearing
plenty of different pieces of
information so i thought
why can't i just speak to an expert who
is pro-covet vaccine and then
anti-covert vaccine have them on this
channel and have them duke it out or
have me be a mediator between them
and it turns out as you search for
information as to why the vaccine is
ineffective
so you can find plenty of information as
the vaccine is what you should take
but as soon as you do search the
opposite then
you don't get much information you only
get about how anti-vaxxers are
obscene idiots and even on google and it
and it seems like if you try to talk
about that the vaccine may not be
the way to go or or there are more
criteria it's not as simple as people
think
it seems like you get demonetized and
it's so it
it drains me so much anthony to think
that i can't even explore this
i want to know for myself i want to know
i'm not an anti-vaxxer
i'm not a provac i don't know man i
don't know i want to know
why can't i get people on my program to
to speak about it without having to
worry that
my day job which is this my the money
that comes in will be dried
up and it's it
it upsets me i'm deeply concerned about
this and
i'll tell you why in the year 1600 a guy
named bruto
jordano bruno was burned at the stake he
was a memory
he was a memory wizard he's the guy that
we get a lot of these techniques from
he memorized and created memory systems
that are so powerful and so profound
and he was burnt at the stake because he
said hey you know what there's an
infinity out there
and quite possibly there are not only
infinite planets
but infinite gods on those planets you
know and uh that was too much
and they they killed them and as a
memory person
i i think that example of him being
burned at that stake
for just saying what he thought is very
timely
or should be more on our minds and i
made a video myself about that when
kappa came
out and i said i said i don't want to
direct to address this issue directly
right because this issue just keeps on
coming and coming
tipper gore when i was a kid put
parental advisory stickers on everything
you couldn't buy a heavy metal
album without being told that it was uh
you know
dangerous or whatever right so this
issue that's happening now is not new it
seems to come in waves and so forth
but the consequences of the of it
should never have to happen again that
people are are being burned
at the stake and they are right now it's
just that there's no fire and there's no
hillary but there's there's
i i i keep using this term symbolic
behavior because i think it's
i think it's really important to to
start seeing that this tribalness
it goes beyond virtue signaling it's
much deeper than that
it's much more nuanced there is there is
something
uh that we could potentially solve about
it but i don't know how and the
implications of machines reading
everything that we're doing
all the time and making decisions on it
in real time
is is not what i would have hoped for
the internet i mean
it should be the opposite yeah yeah it
is
it doesn't it's not pleasant to think
about
and there's a guy named jonathan pajot
who has a wonderful channel called the
symbolic world that you might like if
you haven't heard of him already
yeah yeah okay so so john it's
okay i was going to recommend him i
recommend that there's something else
that reddit apparently is toying with
not sure if this is true or not not sure
but apparently they're toying with
they can ban your account yes for
whatever reason like let's say they
think you're a white supremacist
they'll ban you but also they're
thinking of
banning you if you've upvoted other
people who have
been banned now that to me is another
step
and then it makes you think well man
what the heck
am i supposed i know for my film better
left than said i was called a white
supremacist even though
i'm brown and even though i don't even
though i admonish
white supremacists in the film it
doesn't matter because
i am apparently going against the
extreme left
and then because you're doing that then
what you are must be the exact opposite
which is a fascist and so on
and hopefully you see that i'm not or i
i hope
that the people who are watching me for
any more than five minutes long can
detect that well it doesn't take it
takes more than five minutes but you
understand
and it's it makes me wonder well what if
i upload some comments about free speech
and then later on talking about free
speech becomes a dog whistle
quote-unquote for
fascism then am i a fascist by
association to reddit and then
how far does that go that's uh
that's tricky that's a that's a
treacherous situation
well you know i don't know where it's
going to go and i don't think anybody
does but we're already seeing
there was already two internets anyway
like with the dark web and so forth
and so we're just going to end up seeing
multiple internets i think
the i mean the implications of it are
there's just going to be more tribal not
less
when we and i think tim berners-lee now
has this new idea
that it's going to be a new internet
called solid um
which would hopefully solve some of
these problems because
at the core of this i think it seems
pretty obvious to me but i could be
wrong
is corporate interest and corporate
interest is you know no way to run
intellectual the intellectual promise of
the internet
to corral search to behave in a
particular way
uh you you know you but then you think
well
were libraries better and no because
libraries
had even more corralling of what was
going to be in those shelves and what
wasn't going to be in them
so you know we end up with multiple
internet so be it but it's not going to
be the great promise of the
oneness that the internet provided of
this seamless fluidity between
my question and your answer you know
and that's tremendously sad to lose when
if we're going to talk about the omega
point and
all that sort of stuff like we had
singularity
with a with an open internet that wasn't
filled with gatekeepers but
who knows but they'll there's other ways
to have
quote unquote internets and we'll
probably look at a future of
an infinity of them but that's not going
to i don't think it's going to have the
gutenberg press
impact that this one had and could
potentially hope to speak
i hope to speak to tim berners-lee i
emailed him i would love to get him on
this channel to talk about
the direction of the new internet oh
well
okay let's see what some people say they
say
that i am living in the set of 2001
spades space odyssey someone said
the backgrounds that's that's the very
good observation
okay then let's see someone says
as we're talking about hal 2000 or
whatever that's what that's what comes
up
right maybe there is a guiding
consciousness that was a
that was a little too on the point that
reference to come up right then
scentless apprentice is that the name of
the
book no that's that's called perfume
it's desperate nirvana right nirvana
song
yeah it's das parfum in german by
patrick suskin
mm-hmm
i think is the name of the hero or the
antihero
better said
okay i'm not gonna take questions from
the live chat because it doesn't seem
like
there are any that i can discern right
now so i'll take the ones from before
the audience questions
many of these i wrongly positioned you
as someone who
aids in the memory of mathematicians so
many of these are
sorry about that so many of these are
questions related to math
we can uh we can talk about that yeah
formulas memorizing formulas is
not that difficult if you develop the
systems to do it
someone says do drugs enhance cognitive
performance and if so like which
that's steve agnew
uh well steve i mean that's neurotropics
and all that sort of stuff is
is an interesting topic my position
would be
do your research and consult a doctor
etc but if you want to improve your
memory as such and improve your
cognition as such
do it for the long term and invest in
getting some
memory skills that enable you to do it
without drugs because
you know in my world in my memory
training world i tell people always be
like the samurai prepared to execute any
last move even with your head cut off
because if you don't have your pills
what's the use of all your cognitive
enhancement
based on pills as opposed to
you know when i showed up at that memory
competition that we've mentioned
i was hungover i had a bad day with my
arthritis i have
psoriatic arthritis i was jet lagged and
i still did half as well
as a guy who has two guinness world
records and i've never competed in a
memory card
congratulations so you know that's what
i have to say to neurotropics for
cognitive performance regesh or rajesh
wants to know how can i improve my short
term memory or working memory
any routines any games yeah i would
build your own games and i would
consider you to consider
or i would ask you to consider memory as
more holistic than short-term working
memory
go for all the levels of memory so
exercise your autobiographical your
semantic
your procedural your figural uh episodic
etc
and the best way to get that holistic
comprehensive training is to build a
memory palace and memorize some stuff
using elaborative encoding using what i
call recall rehearsal
and you know doing it about four times a
week at least
for the next 90 days and you will be
amazed by what happens
have you heard of thomas aquinas's art
of memory
yes well i don't know that he has a text
of that but i do know his
memory writings and
one of the things he says in there is
that memory favors organization
and he gives some specific steps about
how to optimize how you organize memory
palaces
and it's very good okay someone wants to
know is addiction related to memory
possibly um there's certainly going to
be a procedural memory component
where you know you get quite addicted to
going through certain rituals and habits
but i don't know enough about addiction
to really comment i know that
i have some times had addiction to go to
the gym
for example but that's a very positive
addiction
so i don't know i'm not an i i'm not i'm
not really a
but why is it a positive addiction like
somehow you get this urge to do it
same i've developed an urge to practice
memory or urge to meditate
uh i don't know enough about it but i'm
sure that its procedural memory is
related at some
level and also external cues like you
can build external cues that help you
remember
memory is not always inside your head it
can also be in the heads of others and
in the world
how long has anthony been practicing his
memory techniques
that's from trollop7 and the previous
question
about i just want to make sure i get
people's names in
the previous question about is addiction
related to memory
that is from mystery bear
okay so thank you for that mystery bear
trollop um
how long have you been practicing your
memory techniques
yeah the answer is 2003 is when i
started and
i started very seriously and i haven't
really started uh
or since i haven't taken any significant
long pauses since 2003.
there are a couple more questions but
i'm going to have to end it there man
thank you so much for being great such a
trooper and
staying with me for maybe three and a
half hours so far
well i i really appreciate the
opportunity to jam and uh
had a blast i love what you're doing uh
and i really um
look forward to more great stuff on your
channel thank you man
do you have a favorite of all the
podcasts just so i know
i'm always interested in as to the
different guests what they like and what
they don't like
um yeah well i like the richard hire one
i like that you recently did your
own first ama that was great um
yeah i mean i just i like the project
overall i i think it has
a focus that's kind of rare on the
internet and
uh you managed to have a like variety
that is still sort of focused on
on a good trajectory so really amazing
thank you man well well i know what i
i know a little bit about the hard work
that goes into it so you know i admire
that i know something from experience
about what goes
what goes into it and then having that
sort of ability to
balance focus and variety is very
challenging so
thank you i appreciate it this is a
great time for me to mention for people
who want to see more conversations like
this that
i do have a patreon it's
patreon.comcarchemongo
and it doesn't seem like it but each
dollar helps every single patient
sorry patient patron every single patron
helps
that's not a parapraxis every single one
helps and
i i even tell my wife like i'm i'm being
honest each one i'm like
babe babe look at this there's someone
to the page and she's like oh my gosh
babe
even if it's a dollar but either way
thank you so much to the people who
who do donate and anthony what do you
need what do you have to plug
i plug your stuff i mean if you're not
supporting or
whatever i mean there's many ways to
support sharing stuff getting involved
in the comments
you know training the robots to care
about
this i would just uh double down on
whatever you can do
and and see the many ways that you can
contribute
i think one of the biggest problems that
we have is that i mean maybe it's an 80
20 rule that governs the universe
but most of the people who are
benefiting the most are seem to be
contributing the least
and then you have like this core 20 who
just contribute like it's because it's
nothing to them right
and it almost it would almost be nice to
see that switch
somehow where the people would really
get that that every penny really does
count
especially when you have all these
forces against you so and
it helps you google me you can google me
i'm not here to pitch but
uh yeah please just please plug yourself
and galactic mma or galactus mma says
the hair looks great that's why i asked
you put a smiley face okay oh well thank
you
just well i assume that person doesn't
want you to think that he was being
sarcastic
so i was so anthony what
do you have to promote where can the
audience find out more about you
i promote memory as such so if you're
interested in improving your memory just
search memory you can search in memory
and anthony i'm sure i come up
but my website is
magneticmemorymethod.com
and i have a youtube channel and uh
yeah i would just encourage people to
really think deeply about your memory
and see that probably some memory
fitness
is going to contribute more to your life
than you can imagine it's not the magic
bullet that cures everything
but your consciousness i think is
produced in large part in collaboration
with your memory so
if you want to jam on those topics then
you know magneticmemorymethod.com is my
headquarters
on the internet thank you so much i do
have
a personal another plug i've been told i
need to mention this more we have itunes
we have spotify we have google play
and sorry google podcast for this
podcast and
i only talk about the youtube channel
but if
ever you're listening or you want to
listen on those platforms please do
leave a review because it helps
and making census says that he left
patreon
he uses paypal to donate i do also have
a paypal
on the youtube i don't know what it's
called about her community page you'll
see it
okay anthony because i don't want it to
just be about me what else can you
promote one more item just to make it
even
well i i really appreciate that people
have been finding my tedx talk
i don't necessarily know why that it
sort of shot up but i i
guess i would my ego would like to see
it shoot up even more because i see it
helping so many people
uh and it will be in the description
the book version of that tedx is called
the victorious mind how to master memory
meditation
and mental well-being and yeah if you
want to read that that's that's great
but i'm happy to uh
if anybody wants that they can't afford
it i can give them a copy of that
that are watching this or listening to
this or whatever just get in touch
uh because the stakes are high memory
really helped me not annihilate myself
at the end of the day
and i'm glad that i didn't even if
i'm not you know so convinced that
there's any uh reason that anything is
existing and that there's no
you know purpose behind anything etc but
in terms of coping with the world has
been the biggest thing for me to
to be able to use memory to refine my
ability to be in the moment and deal
with whatever comes and so i'm
pretty devoted to helping others who
want to do the same and uh
so yeah it helps me every penny helps if
you buy that book of course and it tells
amazon to
show it to more people but uh if you
can't for whatever reason reach out and
i will get you a copy
i recommend it i started reading it
today in preparation for this and i
thought i could finish it in about 30
minutes
i wasn't able to and i definitely
wouldn't have been able to retain it but
i recommend it from what i've read so
far thank you anthony
hope to see you again and thank you for
being so generous with your time
thank you for having me it's a great
pleasure
you